[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
nothing is faster and more exhilarating
in chess than a bullet game it's all
about quick thinking and taking
advantage of every opportunity when it
comes blink and you'll miss it how did
he do that despite its popularity bullet
chess only has one annual championship
tournament and now entering its fifth
year the bullet Chess Championship is
stronger than ever three-time Champion
Hikaru Nakamura again looks to defend
his title and add to his impressive
trophy case a brutal finish Nakamura
officially has won the only player who
has ever stopped Nakamura in this event
also returns to take another shot at it
2021 Champion alireza farugia that's it
competing with these champions for the
first time in the format the best
all-around player in the world Magnus
Carlson has dominated chess seemingly
forever but he's never played in the
bullet Chess Championship will one of
these big three of bullet take home the
twenty thousand dollar crown or can
someone else claim the title maybe Nara
ditsky Tang Hansen Carolina
that is the Fabiano finale in this
speediest of speech has championships
only one Champion will emerge
welcome to the 2023 bullet Chess
Championship
[Music]
welcome everybody to Championship Friday
here at the bullet Chess Championship
I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess alongside me
hey what's up Danny wrench
thanks for having me I've been a fan
I've been watching all week and I'm
super excited to be here it's the final
day I can't wait to see what happens
it's Friday are you are you not gonna
hold anything back I just want to be
clear
I'm not gonna hold anything back last
game of the year Dan nothing to hold
back now it's Friday Friday gotta play
bullet on Friday whatever you want today
we're going to bring it and the chess I
don't think we could ask for a better
end here with maybe the four best bullet
best players in the world throwing down
oh we have exciting chests for you all
today it is the BCC and there are only
four players left standing we started
with 16. that has been whittled down to
the four names you see on the screen in
front of you Daniel nerdinski took down
OLX Hunter Bortnick Magnus Carlson had
his way with Andrew tang and up at the
top it seems like his name is always
etched in the Grand Final it's a car
Nakamura who beat alireza fuja 16 and a
half 12 and a half that sent ferrugia
down to the losers final where he awaits
the winner of the upcoming match between
Daniel nerdinski and Magnus Carlson so
Danny we start the day with the prophet
the Sensei what are your expectations
for this Fifth and final day of the BCC
well Anya against Magnus right obviously
that's going to be where the focus is
because that's where we start winner
plays alireza I think a lot of people
look at that and think Magnus Carlson
world champion but Dania Dania can be a
a streaking creature when he's confident
when he's rolling he can be a force and
uh I wouldn't be surprised that if Dania
gets off to a hot start that he might be
capable of moving on and playing all the
arrests so I'm pumped I'm pumped to see
that obviously a Magnus alireza uh
losers final to see who gets the car
when the Grand Final would probably be
um epic as well so anyway I'm I'm ready
I'm ready for all of it and I think what
I said is true not to take anything away
from all the other players I think these
are the four best bullet players on the
planet and so we have what we want here
on Friday
oh I won't disagree with that statement
these four have been the best that's for
sure and I also concur with you that if
Dania is in the form that we've seen
over the last few days and Magnus if he
has been shaky like he was against
minlay he needs to improve on that as
Oliver said he needs to level up but no
matter who gets through that matchup
they'll still need to play farugia and
then the winner of that and the losers
final goes up to play the Grand Final
against Sakara Nakamura so what I'm
saying is all roads lead tekaru
he's good man he's good he can take on
D5 with check and the problem is now he
has one magic attack he's got to turn
the game around he's just giving up his
bishop and he's giving what's going on
here oh Michael and he's getting mated
he's thinking about winning when he's
losing and then he's going to demoralize
you when he does that Andrew quickly
winning a couple games in a row that
is really important for him oh my gosh
he allowed a Checkmate as soon as I said
winning a
cup gets it done again just reminds us
uh Robert Wise on top of the bullet
world
he is your three-time bullet chess
champion he's also been on a rampage in
this year's Edition you see big wins
over Ohanian Martinez and nariditsky
ferrugia that was a hotly contested
match it was close until the very end
but Denny
73-32 overall that's the score in favor
of Nakamura
at the margin of Victory there is insane
I know there's all kinds of saber
metrics Advanced analytics uh about in
other sports and we continue to have
those types of historical references as
this event is now in its fifth year and
I think as we're looking back at this
event in 20 years Robert there will be
conversations like will anybody ever
have a margin of Victory as dominant as
Hikaru Nakamura you will have
conversations about whether anyone can
touch that type of performance because
73 and 32 is just insane against this
field this isn't like he's farming you
know a 2400. you know what I mean but
not playing me here right he's playing
the best bullet players on the planet
and just dominating it's it's insane
it's been incredible to watch when hikar
was in Peak form it feels like he's
Unstoppable but two players who would
like their chance to face off against
Hikaru and maybe not just once but twice
if they can get all the way the Grand
Final win are Daniel neraditsky and
Magnus Carlson and they're awfully
impressive themselves you see Dania has
played 30
591 games maggots over 1 000 bullet
games himself the average accuracy well
in Max's favor but the peak rating in
Dunya so what of these numbers which of
them stand out to you Danny
we could probably talk about this image
honestly Robert for like a half an hour
I mean honestly it's 30 000 Games first
of all is insane but let's remember that
includes hyper bullet as well we know
that Dania loves himself some late night
hyper bullet if you check out his
streams but also look at the wins by
flag 28 wins by Flag by Daniel which
proves that as impressive as that
accuracy is by the world champion who
plays 80 accurate 86 accuracy chess and
bullet Magnus Carlson does but it shows
that winning games getting the dub is
what matters in bullet right and you
don't have to play accurate chess when
you're tricking your opponent with
awkward blunders in a Time scramble that
make them plaque so Donya donja knows
how to get the job done and um I think
that that's a really important stat
right there that 28 wins by flag yeah
diet promoted to a night earlier in the
competition just to not just confuse his
opponent but to make them spend more
time as you were saying and you're
completely correct that it's not about
being the most accurate you need to be
lightning fast and Magnus has been very
strong out of the gates he actually had
a huge speed when he was playing as far
Asia but against Dania I mean down the
stretch of those games it's going to be
difficult the mouse speed is there for
Donya but look at the new setting behind
Magnus he's back home he was in
Barcelona with the chess bras that
should help his cause
yeah we'll see how comfortable he is now
that he's uh in the in the setup that
we've we've come to know and love with
multiple chairs behind him as I was just
in Oslo I feel like every day was like
constant commentary on the chair setup
um I think there's a couple of secret
lab chairs they're hiding so yeah Magnus
now back home looks to be ready and uh I
think as as we said though Robert I
think because of donya's style and how
well he can play when he gets rolling if
he's confident and because we know how
good Magnus Carlson is an early start an
early and early good result for Matt for
Donya is really critical here
yeah you cannot let Magnus get out to a
three-game lead Magnus wins the first
three games that puts Donnie in trouble
especially because we have 30 minutes of
this match so you can't go down early
against Magnus but what dania's done
well Danny is against Hikaru in the
second game of their match he was
completely lost blunder to peace he
played it out and actually held a draw
in a Time scramble
yeah well and he's gonna need to do more
of that right and show why he wins a lot
of games by flagging we saw we saw the
stats earlier was 28 for those of you
just tuning in a lot of games to win by
flag lagging but that means he also
draws a lot of games in time scrambles
right he's not an easy person to put
away and so Dania has to be ready for
the fight has to be uh has to not be
intimidated by the fact that he's
playing um maybe maybe the greatest
player of all time right and I think if
he keeps himself focused and and does
what he does Dania has a very good
chance to move on it and face all the
resin and the nerves can't get to either
player right now because even Andrew
tank who's usually the most Zen of all
players said he was nervous when he's on
his last life in this double elimination
format so there is a lot at stake right
now because you get the chance to play
against farrugia that's all good and fun
but you're guaranteed minimum 12K if you
win this match the loser on the other
hand eliminated into fourth place gets
eight thousand dollars not a bad chunk
of change for the player who does and
their tournament run here but you want
that extra four thousand dollars you
want that chance against fruition
ultimately you want to go play against a
car and beat him in the Grand Final
yeah everyone wants a chance at the King
right you want a chance to Hikaru
Nakamura of course he did win uh he
hasn't won every bullet Chess
Championship we all remember the year
that all the Reza managed to get the job
done and take him down but overall a
margin of Victory speaks for itself when
it comes to Hikaru um everyone as we as
we showed earlier all roads lead to
Hikaru so everyone wants that chance but
yeah not a bad chunk of change 100 grand
total in prizes for the bullet Chess
Championship and uh these guys are ready
we uh we've got we've got a Magnus
Carlsen singing on camera that you're
all going to see here in just a second
so you know Magnus is ready when he's
like bobbin probably some Taylor Swift
can we be honest that Magnus I bet he
finds his Groove With A Little T Swift
on a Friday afternoon in Norway
hey you know whatever gets him going and
I think that deserves to be the music in
his ears but Dania he looks focused and
I know he has been so Daniel of course
good friend as the game start but he has
really been dedicated to this event
going to sleep earlier Denny you should
be proud
oh my gosh if that's all I needed to do
to get donja to go to bed earlier we
should hold a bullet event every week
Jokes Aside anyone who follows Jess
commentary knows that Dania dania's done
you know he's had his late nights
knowing he needed to wake up at the at
six a.m the next day for commentary so
um but we love him and he's been getting
his rest look at him he looks like he
showered he's fresh now he's leaned in
and uh forgets that he's he's a
commentator and now he's just a player
doesn't care how he looks on camera
right now yeah and he shouldn't me he
should care about his position looks
because I see holes in White's position
and Magnus hops Knight to C4 all these
light squares under magnus's control and
the clock a five second lead currently
for Magnus I think he's got great chance
to take game on with black
yeah and this move A5 is is super nice
obviously already focused on opening the
a file prying down the A3 Pawn I know
it's bullet but positional chest still
matters oh my gosh an E3 crumbling the
king behind it Dania is uh feeling the
hurt here in the first game yeah Bishop
takes D4 black is going up at minimum in
exchange uh is a good effort there oh
there's Queen D4 please take my queen oh
no my queen yeah you take there there
was a back rank mate on E8
nice little trap oh no my queen and uh
uh Donya is gonna try for every trick in
the book in the books even when he's
down against Magnus today so oh plenty
more where that came from wow so Magnus
allowed Rook D7 because he had spotted
Rook A1 check now Magnus up a full Rook
into this end game and has plenty of
time to convert the win
yeah time is critical here any game
we're evaluating a Magnus Carlson
Advantage you have to look at the clock
before you uh chalk it up to the books
right there Magnus Carlson does take the
first game with black
and he's ready he's back home feeling a
little more comfy maybe and uh here we
go
and this looks like a caracon to me but
it started with D4 Knight F6 so it was a
jabala London turned into a sort of
caracon turned into whatever this is and
I feel like Dania uh he is going to be
down on the clock in the early stage of
the game Magnus is the better prepared
player between the two something Hikaru
said that Dania has been changing his
openings against Naka and maybe against
some of the other top players and that
could actually be detrimental rather
than helpful because you spend time but
actually look at this tactic from done
that's a super nice trick the F2 poem is
hanging I think that's a great point
though overall when you're not playing
positions that you're comfortable with
where the plans are almost subconscious
it can really hurt you in bullet when
you really need to play quickly on the
clock so if delanya has to change his
openings against top players not a great
sign oh and look at that he blundered
his Knight oh man he had such a good
position
that's super unfortunate that move Rook
D1 by Magnus took away a checking square
and now Dania resigns because he's
losing his Rook on D7 to follow so that
must be frustrating you steal a pawn
with a nice tactic and then a few moves
later you blunder a piece in the center
we talked about that a lot I know it's
hard to get instructive moments in
bullet but you can't take for granted
that a tactic may not have worked the
move before Robert your opponent does
something that makes it work and you are
you were borderline pre-moving and so
you blundered Magnus really heads up
play there to take away that Queen D4
check and actually renew the threat of
F3 and he wins the game yeah and now we
get into this third game here in Magnus
with the black pieces trying to stop
Checkmate he does but his Pawn structure
is shattered great position I would say
for Donna he's also keeping steady on
the clock but now Magnus will he show
that end game technique that's made him
the highest rated player in history
and you called it though out of the
gates I I said Donya needs to make sure
he doesn't fall behind you specifically
said that a 3-0 deficit would be really
really problematic and right now Johnny
is staring down the barrel of that gun
and look at that though he's rising to
the occasion he's one upon now too he's
got three passers good stuff here from
Donya to make sure he doesn't fall
behind three games DCF smile Donna
smiles and took a drink all right that
was actually very adorable
can we flip and ship that please that's
what that's the feeling you know the
feeling of beating a world champion that
video we did of artemiev that's the
feeling of beating a world champion and
bullet right there big smile from Don
yanir diski yeah I'd love to see that
Magnus does not like to see that because
you do not want to give Dania that kind
of confidence but donya's in that flow
state where he's just moving I mean his
intuition is superb and so Magnus knows
that he respects that and here with the
white pieces Magnus is taking all the
space in the position but when you push
punts forward you leave them vulnerable
in the future so watch out for this E4
Pawn in particular and also his B4 upon
yeah the B4 opponent is look at that
Donya finds a trick because if you took
you would have lost the Knight on F3
dude and look at that now he wins The
Exchange Don you're rolling if he evens
up this match that's the confident Donya
we called that would be capable of
winning today he's got to get out to a
good start early and I love how he's
playing but did you see that by Magnus
trading Queens went down material
because the Rook slides up then you lose
the Rook to the other Bishop that was
actually sick from Magnus the ability to
spot all that in the blink of an eye
oh but look at Donya right back at it
with the trick himself with that G5 move
that saved the exchange that was nasty I
don't know that he's gonna win but look
he might be on on Route is there a
mating net here there has to be where is
it I was thinking Rook takes F6 but I
don't think that worked just yet but oh
yeah
oh Bishop Bishop F3 and then Rook G6 and
then Bishop
what is happening here this looks very
important yeah
E6 the pawn pushes and then is there 86
chicken
oh my gosh and it's falling apart wait
for G6 Rook G6 oh
coming oh the wrong piece why do you
take G5 he's baited back here
oh my God Brook takes F6 was good not
Richie five oh and Donnie just making a
few moves resigns and look at the smile
on his face he's like I cannot believe
that I just out calculated Magus Carlsen
and then still made a mistake and lost
that is what the bullet just
Championship is made of right there
games like that of course we see the uh
the real time engine analysis show and
there were obviously a number of
blunders and Miss wins there but it
doesn't matter it's entertaining chess
and Donya misses his opportunity to
level the score
okay but he goes right back into the
game and he's playing quickly and he's
got a french-like structure and it's the
best French I've ever seen black doesn't
have a light Square Bishop uh the pawn
structure is shattered on the Queen's
head for white but black castles into
the pressure Danny we usually say the
side with a safer King is used inside
with the advantage in bullet I don't
think black's King is particularly safe
wax king is not safe Donya is uh
very easy planes here I think to play on
the queen side the knights popping into
D6 just as you highlight look at that
move d4 this is an easy position for
white to play which is key and bullet
swing The Rook back over yep he does it
I like we're done just going here got to
keep this thing close very instructed
from Dania his Rook was on B1 pressuring
the the black king and he just says let
me go over to the king side and oh he
did just drop two Pawns in a row one of
them would check H spawn may be
dangerous Danny
yeah the h-phone is super dangerous the
king is also in an awkward spot there oh
he was threatening Rook G6 and Rook H6
crazy that the engine can say this is an
equal position that's so unfair to chess
it is but look at the clock as you say
who cares what your accuracy is look at
the time I think that Dania yep should
try to flag Magnus here
100 agreed that you can't let games like
this go by you gotta flag him especially
when there's a knight on the board right
so many tricks possible like Orcs
in fact that's a huge heads up play by
Magnus to get the knights off the board
dirty flag him it's Rook against rook
and pawn who cares do not repeat moves
give checks and if you're Magnus you
probably just do not push the pawn that
way you get the 50 move rule yep yep
yeah at this point the writing is on the
wall but you're not gonna have enough
time to win if you're Magnus so don't
push the pawn and take the draw
no draw this isn't it for Bobby Fischer
that's a win for Daniel nerdinsky
he raises his hand apologetically Dania
is such a sweetheart for those who don't
know the level of respect Dania has for
just the sanctity of the game of chess
as someone who Flags people a lot 28 of
his victories you should just know the
under feels bad about every single dirty
flag he's ever done genuinely that was
that was like in tennis when you hit a
really hard shot and then it hits the
net and then gently rolls over and
you're like sorry about that like you
got the point the way you needed to
there was nothing unethical about it so
Donya he is now only down by one point
his position looks really bad from the
black side and by the way we saw that
chat voted and 22 percent of you believe
in Dunya the 70 other 78 think Magnus is
going to win
yeah I don't think that's a huge
surprise Magnus wins a lot of votes uh
when people ask who's gonna win a match
look at this there's a trick here on the
board
White's D7 Pawn I guess is going to rule
the day here in the end that's the
problem
D7 and well we'll push don't look at
that by Max do not take the bishop
because the king would have rushed over
to E7 to win the pawn so Bishop E3 a
stellar Retreat and here comes the
bishop to C7 and that should be it
okay nice heads up defense though
getting the all but Magnus he'll have
none of it you will not slow down the
pawn a little head Bob that t Swift you
know hitting it
didn't it let's just hope it's not Carly
Rae Jepsen whoa nothing wrong with Carly
Rae yeah wait what do you gotta I just
what
what just happened there why you why I
said that why are you going against
Carly Rae Jepsen why don't we talk about
Sean Mendes for a second whoa Knight D6
that pose whoa 96 check he plundered it
and donjo Don Just Smiles but Magnus
laughing a little bit oh wait it's not
over I thought it was just over when he
this is very complicated game where
Black's up in exchange and look at that
awareness from Magnus Queen H5 gets
those Queens off the board but black
apparently isn't even better but black
does have two Rooks the whites one
yeah this is completely turned around
for a game that started with a knight D6
check borderline smothered mate Magnus
gets the Queens off the board heads up
play which makes his King safe and now
he should be winning in this end game
but I'm looking at the clocks and
anytime I see Magnus within a couple
seconds of Dania I'm actually worried
for Magnus because done it is faster in
these time scrambles there's plenty of
time left too much extra material for
black for the moment but done it is
smart to play this out
totally agreed especially if you're not
down you know at this point there's
still 19 minutes left in the match
you're not in a position where you need
a new game to get a oh and he finds a
fork just like that it's turning back
around second Knight D6 of the game and
that's going in donya's way still up
upon is Magnus Carlsen and he's up a
couple seconds but I'm telling you Magus
would want to be up four seconds into
time scrambles because janya is faster
yep you could already sort of smell the
dirty flag coming here you can like you
can smell it and and Magnus can feel it
too look at the level of pre-moving that
he's engaged here
hoping for a draw
oh no Magnus played on it actually wants
more madness is slightly ahead of the
clock but Don just can't gets back at
times in the box so the black king will
eat D3 as it might be a draw no anyway
okay whoo Danny but Donnie was look
objectively and he fought back because
he knows when to resign and when to play
on
and I was actually surprised by magnus's
decision to keep pushing there I think
that if he does that too many times
you might regret it because especially
when you have a two-game lead I would be
okay with the draw rather than take my
chances in a dirty flag competition with
Donya I don't want to be in a dirty fly
competition with that guy right and so
I'm a little I'm a little surprised by
that risk that risk there that Magnus
took yeah because yesterday hikar
against alireza Hikari won bishop and
Rook Pond a draw because it was the
wrong color Bishop for the corner a
couple times he just flagged all the
rays are the same exact end game we
almost saw for the second time this
match Rook against rook and a couple
pawns to a win in time trouble right now
we're seeing Dania try to use the queen
side to his Advantage he's down in
exchange not the first time today we've
seen that but he's gobbling up Queen
side pawns and that's a passer yep
yeah this is I mean objectively a very
balanced position in bullet it's
actually hard to choose which side is
easier to play the Bishops in the past
bomb feel good but long term that night
will be tricky in the time scramble but
look at that move Bishop A2 he said your
move your rook's useless and Bishop H6
Bishop C1 how is white gonna defend this
you have to go Knight A3 at the end of
it oh
Magnus Magnus
I don't know what he anticipated there
unclear but Dania is in charge and look
at the clock by the way not only is
Dania probably better with the two
Bishops versus The Rook he is well ahead
on time and as long as he doesn't
blunder a piece he should be able to
take this game
agreed
yeah this is uh the onions game to win
look at the time Advantage just
increasing or near disc here
this is the position Magnus is afraid of
doesn't want to be in these spots
dania's gonna I think bring this thing
within a game here and if I'm done yeah
I don't usually happen no how many moves
have been made but I might throw in G4
at the moment trying to catch me oh yeah
I gave him a part so lose it upon is
actually a good thing because there's no
50 move ruling oh but that's not good oh
that's not a good thing but Magnus only
has two seconds not gonna oh he's gonna
get everything off the board oh he had a
chance to take the bishop he had a
chance oh
wow
wow what a save by Magnus there and that
is unfortunate for Donya because that
was a rare chance to get a victory he
didn't take it yeah that was a save by
Magnus so he's proving you guys may call
me out and say I can't handle myself in
the scrambles he said no this one I have
under control but honestly that was done
to blundering a piece he was trying to
pre-move uh the way through and now with
the white pieces though look at this for
Donna apparently it's just winning for
white
is keeping with it here and you know not
only is he better in these well he's
consistently up on time Magnus did just
hold his own in that scramble oh dania's
been playing a high level of Chess here
Bishop A6 what a tricky move he
plundered look at this The Rook is not
gonna attack before there's F5 yeah and
if you defend the Rook then you lose the
knight at the end so I think
what is houses equal
is it some sort of Shaq in Queen H4
regarding the Rook no at the end there's
you know what it is Danny it's Rook
takes A8 and Knight D7 Knight of fate
and then the king can't escape oh my god
with a Perpetual but that's impossible
to find
I don't think Magnus sees it and I
definitely think Dania doesn't see it
because he's clearly frustrated he
actually just resigned oh my gosh that's
one of those where the engine is just so
unfair for us but it is actually a
really cool thing because the
instructive moment of this this
perpetual and night of hey we never
would have spotted no if not for the
computer saying the position was leveled
I mean we sat there clueless for a
little bit and how is this equal and
like okay you're telling me it's equal
any queen move seems to lose a piece so
let's go for that and that is ridiculous
you can't expect to find that even in a
Blitz game and bullet no shots Dania
with the black pieces he just stole a
pawn he's actually playing quite well in
this match
agreed
yeah here he goes he's up at one
and uh up on the clock significantly by
the way yeah this is an opportunity to
stay with it get it back within a couple
games after that that crazy loss
but Magnus is also you know he's playing
he's pulling it down here too even when
he's losing he's making it hard he's
dragging it out and if he does have a
lead it's in his it's in his best
interest to get as much time off the
clock as possible only 13 minutes remain
right now well we have a blender
let's go that was a nice game from start
to finish as Daniel secures his fourth
point in the match is now six to four
and we have to remember that it's win by
two so as long as Daniel can cut this to
a one point deficit even if time elapses
he's still in this
all right what do we got now we've got a
simple boring looking symmetrical
position but Dania on the prowl
I like the way you described it you know
yeah they just traded up all the pieces
only e-file is open this looks like it
should be drawish but I'm looking at the
clock I think Dania perfectly happy with
equal positions where there are pieces
left on the board and he can try to
outplay magnets although with that move
is he saying I'm okay with the draw
yeah I wonder it's
probably true that he's okay with a draw
on this one but I don't know that Magnus
will take that we know the Magnus is
super tricky we saw him okay he does
take control I'm gonna say we saw him
win two night end games against his
buddy Jordan Von Far East at the
Champions chest tour last week of course
a little bit of a different format in a
rapid setting than a bullet setting but
uh but okay and I wonder if Dania if he
really needs to win that game let's say
there was the last game of the match I
mean he would have played that out and
maybe he could have posed some problems
because he is that fast and credit to
Magnus because Magnus he's improved his
game I think the Magnus we're seeing Now
is better than we've seen in the last
few days uh he is leveling up as alireza
said he had to
yeah agreed he's playing uh playing
better again more focused maybe a little
more comfy in his home setting than he
was on the road
whether it's enough to get by Dania
alireza and Hikaru Nakamura okay that's
uh that's gonna be quite the tale of
Magnus can complete a comeback and
ultimately win today but we'll we'll
deal with that later right now we've got
a rook end game with Queens on the board
ganya again holding a Zone
but Magnus up on the clock here yeah he
is up a few seconds he gets his Queen in
oh but speaking of Queen in that could
be scary for the king and Magnus he
offers the queen should A3 B6 both under
attack because of the Rope placement for
white so whoa is dandy going for more
with that B5 move
I think he is and I think he should the
past a pawn
you know whether objectively Black's
better or not poses some problems
practically for white look at this he
wants to break up he loses the best
apron right as I say it and Magnus has
turned it around
Donya on the defensive oh
can't take him okay seven Rook a seven
yeah
that's a problem so that means others
yeah Max up too much time Danny
yeah he's gonna play Rook B8 and then
stack the queen on C7 oh but watch out
for the draw oh
oh what yeah why did it go very far down
there not sure
a second Queen but there's a main thread
on G2 okay not anymore yeah it was it
was there for people we've seen games
already where someone's Queen didn't
help them stop mate earlier in the
bullet Chess Championship this week so
not to be
not to be there for Donya Magnus
increases his lead
I mean really nicely down there by
Magnus converting that Advantage he
stole the A3 pawn and never looked back
and here Dania is playing one of his pet
lines it's this jabala London system
where look at these Knights these nights
are on dark squares that's a bishop on a
light Square I'll put the knights in
green but they're outclassing that light
Square Bishop which is staring to thin
air
yeah
so pretty night's on dark squares
oh queen queen C8
apparently not great hey that rhymed
but now we're rolling what is going on
here look at this
let's go Mega sect is rook and then it's
at the pawn in the center this is
getting very confusing but it looks like
Magnus has gone astray
it looks like he's got astray but I
don't I don't with every move the
evaluation seems to change and then
there was a potential Knight F2 so the
Queens come off the board
a practical perspective I don't know who
is easier to play though in bullet here
that d-pawn is so dangerous and you have
to sacrifice for it so he's gonna give a
check oh he's making the draw that he
could have had in the other game but I
wonder but is there a mating net is
there ah there's no nothing more than a
draw yeah this Pawn too strong
ah
and Daniel he spent a bit of time there
it's calculating but he needs all the
time he's just making sure but he needs
the time that's the thing if you want to
win no you're right it's tough yeah
no I don't disagree that you got to make
those decisions as fast as you can but I
think John you just wanted to make sure
he wasn't missing right right we have
the luxury of the Ebel bar saying it's a
draw he didn't want to walk away from
from a mating net
um all right structure with G3
Magnus knows these positions well and
now is this move G4 wow
and oh this queen lands in the center
but Rook hits it and is there an attack
this G4 Pawn is loose over here but
maybe there's a problem if you take it
the G file opens up against the black
king
and trying to see it does take it that's
a brave decision from Donya and he's in
sort of that must win territory so why
not go for it and we might see another
repetition
clever stuff here from Magnus
and Roberto from Magnus to save the draw
we're now sorry what how's it Magnus is
not moving because he has the draw by
repetition this is where gamesmanship
comes in he's only going to make that
draw when he's down to like two seconds
left
we see donjo uh sorry we see Magnus
juggling all the players know that
there's that kind of larger meta
strategy in these SCC formats whether
it's the bullet Chess Championship or
the teachers Championship you have to
use the clock but it kind of makes them
laugh because that's such an element
that has never existed in chess right
before this format where you're
basically playing another game that
isn't on the board and uh you gotta
respect it because
what he's doing there Robert is saying
that he respects dania's ability to make
a comeback right so don't take it the
wrong way he's like look I'm milking the
format here because I know what bullet
is I know what Dania is capable of and
I'm gonna get every second off the clock
that I can yeah it's a smart strategy
we've seen hikara do that over the years
and I saw a feature chat saying the
Hikaru way yeah the best players who
have been around who have played these
formats they know what to do and Magnus
castles Queen side and we're gonna see
it Alpha zero style open up this H file
and go for an attack
Here Comes Harry Simon Williams not with
us today but always here in spirit Airy
for the win
and uh that's going to be very dangerous
for Donya and Dania has to just drum up
some Queen side pressure uh if he can
but oh no Danny the pawns are dropping
in front of the white Kings feels too
dangerous
this is looking this is looking painful
and a victory here would stretch the
lead to four games with probably roughly
six and a half minutes left this is uh
uh getting hard it's win or go home and
it needs to start right about now if
you're done yet because Magnus is almost
in the territory where he can just start
letting the clock hit yeah let's see
with six minutes and 30 seconds
remaining and done and needing to score
three wins in a row to cut it to one so
there is enough time barely but Daniel
needs to win the next three games
oh I gotta start now off to a oh yeah
he's pre-moving everything weird
position here he blundered upon because
he's like pre-moving Non-Stop
oh
it's good strategy you might lose this
game but a draw to loss is the same for
the match so you need to move instantly
win instantly and Don is doing all he
can
yeah
War Games is the deficit you don't want
a typical five but you're in that weird
spot Robert where If you defend this
position for a minute for a minute
longer and hold a draw that hurts too
because you just lost another minute on
the clock and didn't get a victory so
Donya needs to find a way to Swindle
this night end game and get a tricky a
tricky win uh I think he swindled
himself there by uh pushing the pawn A6
behind
oh and Magnus he might not even want to
win he's going for the win but I thought
he just might make the draw there yeah
Knight D3 Knight C5 was a draw there but
he wants more
a win here essentially puts the match
away right we never want to call it too
soon but it's getting tough it's gonna
be under five minutes with a five game
def instead
oh man this was awesome though is it
weird that I'm already excited for next
year's bullet Chess Championship and
we're right here you know what I'm
already like you know why I'm excited
for that Danny and this is not a shout
out in a bad way it's a shout in a good
way nihal sarin wherever you are right
now I know you're probably gonna watch
this at some point please play you're
invited I know you're busy but we would
love to see nihal join the party because
we have the best bullet players on the
planet here and I feel like Neil's
really the name that is absent from this
field
I completely agree
um it'll also help with the uh the
Twitter hate that I received from all of
your fans in India knee how sarin
because they thought we didn't invite
you of course we invited you and so next
year you have to play that uh so that
people know we didn't mess that up
and well this match it's in the books by
right now A five-point margin and we'll
see how it ends but you can see Magnus
bopping his head he's a different Magnus
than we saw earlier in the competition
he is back home that probably helps he's
on his normal setup but he's also just
playing a lot better and I would say
faster in the scrambles when he was uh
playing from Barcelona Danny I don't
know if you watched this part he was
like shaking his hand after every game
he said his hand was falling asleep he
didn't have a good setup so at home
Magnus seems to be increasingly
dangerous for the opposition
it sounds silly but this format as much
as anything brings out the sporting
elements of the physical setup players
have at home right you need a table that
supports your wrist I mean seriously
right if you're on an awkward table and
your wrist is on the edge everyone has
had that right you can't play with a
touchpad unless you're Robert Hess you
know I mean seriously you need your
setup to do well and and the physical
elements of whatever whatever makes
chess an esport if you want to call that
are really highlighted in this event and
uh and we'll see if that is enough to
help Magnus turn around his fortunes and
and maybe maybe make it all the way to
the Grand Final
and I'm not gonna lie we can already
start talking about it I still see
alireza as the favorite in the next
round I love Dania we're not looking
past him but this one's over and I think
that Perugia Magnus is uh we're about to
break the internet here and I think Ole
Reza is still the slight favorite
against the former World Camp not sure
if you agree he did beat Magnus a couple
days ago and he started with a 3-0 lead
and the final margin was a three-point
match victory for Ali Reza so I think
that Alvarez has proven himself to be
the best Contender to uh Hikaru
nakamura's title in fact alireza won the
2021 edition of this event by beating
Hikaru and wow as we look at this
position Magnus well on his way to
another Victory it would seem with a
huge attack and a huge lead on the clock
I I think that you're right that other
is the favorite but Magnus in this form
the way he just demonstrated his bullet
skills against Dania here I think that
he's showing that he should not be
overlooked himself
I agree I agree
well we're gonna see what happens here
in probably about 15 minutes in total
fans go call everybody be like hey what
are you doing why are you working it's
Friday come watch the bullet Chess
Championship because the bleep is about
to go down it is Friday people you know
man they might take it easy and the real
question is are you sitting in the front
seat or sitting in the back seat
right
I either way I'm having a party party
and partying with you party and yeah I
don't remember exactly the line but hey
here we go
oh what's 97 what happened there was a
fork
pork pork down E7 Town C5 hangstown
you're only going to get a wind Town
yeah no Dania he has played a really
good match so even though the the margin
of Victory right now is quite heavily in
magnus's favor part of that was induced
by the lack of time where he he played
not even bullet chess he put hyper
bullet in a one minute game uh but
Magnus is a deserved winner but I think
what I'm trying to say is that Dania has
proven himself to be a seriously awesome
player and we knew that but it's also
good to see him against Hikaru against
Magnus and they're going to be the only
two people who have beaten them
yeah well I mean especially because
Johnny is a guy you watch play bullet so
much right everyone is a fan of of down
your disc stream and and I think
sometimes the haters if you want to call
them that would be like ah but how does
Donya do against the best guys in the
world and we see he holds his own he
beats these guys and and frankly I think
there were a couple games earlier in
this match but if they had gone the
other way because bullet is such a game
of momentum who knows right and again
the final score is what it is for a
reason Magnus Carlson is going to win by
probably roughly six percent six games
here even if Dundee gets this one
but
but I I think donya's chess has been
better than the final result so that's
my long-winded way of saying I agree
with you Robert
and I love you I I appreciate both of
those things
um and we are gonna get one more game so
15 seconds on the match clock and done
just happened to the heat as you were
saying earlier he has so much respect
for the game of chess but he has this
loyalty to the game so much that he
respects the top players maybe too much
at times I think that he recites number
like he doesn't want to flag them he put
up his hands but you have to be
Shameless in the bullet Chess
Championship there are no friends as we
found out yesterday when he played his
good friend oh it's under Bortnick but
Dania he gets one more game he relishes
the opportunity to play against the best
of the best and right now all right in
this final one he is worse but let's see
if he can pull out another Victory one
for the road
yep
thank you for the money one for the road
for you to get ready and four to go
one wait that I said it wrong but you
get it yeah I know what you're trying to
do
and uh Hey Okay the Bishops are uh are
nasty but Knights are tricky in a Time
scramble so if you can keep it close
Magnus by the way is just like feeling
it right we saw him DJing the other
night or something now we see him just
bobbing his head and uh
he's in his own I think there's
something therapeutic when you're in the
flow as you I think that's what you said
earlier when you're in the flow
listening to music playing a game you
love
I think the players really really love
this format
yeah and I think Magnus loves the fact
that he's moving on he gets another
chance against alderiza and we know that
Vengeance it motivates some people and
Magnus not really an exception of that
and he says winning once that's not
revenge and he would like to take down
all the reason imagine Dania going for a
little cheeky I love it
[Music]
look at that look at this
don't you laughed the bag is just like
wait what to a night does Magnus have
Auto Queen on take it and get a knight
take it yeah hold alt and promote you at
night we're gonna definitely make sure
Magnus knows that
that was that was good by the way
advance for the inside joke in case
you're not realizing it's stalemate if
you take the Rook that's what's going on
here
in fact just plays along oh that was so
good so good I don't think Magus knows
how to that he is doesn't have to Auto
Queen if he holds down alt and Hammer
has experienced that his compatriot and
his friend so Dania he gets a draw that
was hilarious a great way to end that
match
yep that was awesome couple of Thumbs Up
Donya acknowledging whatever our team is
telling him behind the scenes producers
fair play I think you might be joining
us for an interview and uh that was
awesome what a fun way to end it Dania
held his own against uh as our as our
show open says the greatest all-around
player of all time will he win the
bullet Chess Championship when today is
done we don't know yet but Magnus does
win this match 12 and a half seven and a
half yeah five-point match victory for
Magnus Carlson and for Dania he was
smiling at the end he deserves to hold
his head up high he put forth a great
fight to Magnus and this is a different
Magnus than in previous days that's
clear to me so Magnus he deserves the
Lion's Share of the praise here beating
Daniel nerdinski by five in a 30-minute
bullet batch uh but Dania I mean there's
nothing to be disappointed about there
it was a really good tournament for him
he beat Andrew Tang by eight points uh
he beat Bortnick he's done very very
well throughout this event he just got
stopped by first ikaru and second Magnus
yeah it's not a bad
it's not a bad story to tell right I
lost a Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus
Carlson you'll take that one along with
the eight grand that you get for playing
uh in the fourth place final position so
uh amazing stuff again I think we called
it we knew that Dunya needed to get off
to a good start if he had managed a
little better there who knows what
happens bullet is such a game of
momentum even more than any other format
we have online and Magnus gets it
rolling and uh couldn't be stopped the
bracket now is down to three remaining
players as Daniel nerdinski exits the
field it is alireza faruja against
Magnus Carlson there in the losers final
and the winner of this match they will
their name will be placed right
underneath Hikaru Nakamura in the Grand
Final so there is a lot at stake in the
match that is coming up but before we
get there we're gonna get an interview
with Daniel naroditski so the chat
please get involved you ask your
questions we'll feature some of them and
I'm just really excited to hear Daniel's
thoughts on the flip side of this break
thank you
this chorus is about white playing D4
all the tools you need to get an
advantage with Wyatt and not be tricked
early in the opening
now it has a really long complicated
name that I'm going to mispronounce now
so you can make fun of me okay don't
make fun of me too much I'm trying to
help you here it's called the cello
binsk variation and I'm probably
mispronouncing chalabins that's why I
call it the A6 sloth
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are now down to the final Trio of
participants here in the bullet Chess
Championship Magnus Carlson he moved on
after defeating Daniel naroditski it was
a fun match it was you know type for a
few there but Magnus pulled away with
impressive speed Eddie
yeah he did and uh he he won on the
board he also held his own on the clock
against uh a guy who as we saw when we
did the head-to-head stats wins 28 of
his bullet games by flagging people
Dania is the best in the biz when it
comes to dirty flagging but Magnus held
his own ultimately got the job done
we'll get the uh we'll get another
chance against the guy who sent him to
the losers bracket and all the rest of
Borussia
and before we see magnets get that
chance we are going to bring in none
other than Dana neraditsky for an
interview adanya sorry that this match
didn't go your way I mean you impressed
so many people along the way I know it
must be tough just to be on the back of
an elimination here but are you glad
that you played and how are you feeling
about your overall level
yeah well thank you very much obviously
I'm really really sad to to be
eliminated and not to have a an outside
shot at at the top three
um but I'm more than happy I played it
was really an honor to to participate in
the tournament my my like minimum goal
was to not make a fool of myself maybe
beat a couple of good players and I knew
that realistically if Magnus and ikaro
play in the best conditions I don't have
much of a chance against them and
um they did and I gave them a really
really good fight I think even this
match was pretty close if a couple of
games had gone my way uh this this could
have been you know a one or two point
match so I'm really proud of the way
that I that I fought against them you
know I'm not I've got nothing to be
embarrassed about I lost a Magnus and
Hikaru and you know I'm more than happy
to take my hat off these two players are
just otherworldly and I really had the
time of my life so
um any any bullet tournament like this
sign me up I'll be the first in line
on you you obviously as you said have
nothing to be embarrassed about at all
losing to take a car Nakamura Magnus
Carlsen is a good thing to write home
about but for so many people you have so
many fans they watch you play they watch
you dominate other people on stream
where you are just worldly you are
otherworldly you are in a class above
the majority of human beings who play
chess especially in bullet so if you if
you don't mind what what is the thing
that separates Magnus and Hikaru a
little bit I may if it's not just one
thing but in the experience of playing
them what did you feel allows them to
just pull away in those big moments
I think Magnus and ikar R2 are two
different beasts so the the formula that
makes each one of them great I think is
is a little bit distinct but without
delving too deeply into the into you
know the particulars of of what
distinguishes the two
um I'll take Magnus because I spoke
about Hikaru a little bit in yesterday's
interview in terms of Magnus um I think
it's you know three or four different
things that he does better than anybody
else on the planet I mean first of all
what Magnus City car both have in common
are openings like I am not a
professional player I don't study
openings I don't have a a seven person
team preparing files for me and when
they take matches seriously like Magnus
did today and they play their main
repertoire their understanding of the
positions that that they're most
comfortable with are off the charts like
they will make a move in one second that
I very likely wouldn't be able to come
up with in a classical game
um it's also the consistency Magnus
today was able to avoid one move
blunders and the blunders he did make
were mostly like a pawn uh or maybe an
exchange and it's very important not to
not blunder because that's not possible
but to make sure the blunders you make
uh don't immediately get you to a lost
position that was the difference between
R2 blunders right not all blunders are
created equal
um so there was that consistency and of
course the speed is is really
unbelievable I'm fast in time scrambles
right like I'm fast in a rook versus
situation
but in the early middle game the speed
with which Magnus makes decisions in
critical moments is crazy like my mouth
literally Falls open and it really is
just an honor to be on the receiving end
of that and to play in a way that allows
Magnus to bring out that strength so I
was happy that you know that that I
forced them to do that but when when
these two players are in their best form
it's literally like playing an engine
you it's it's almost indistinguishable
uh done I mean we'd love to hear that I
mean the admiration respect you have for
them is clear to all and I I just want
to know that you smiled when you got
your first Victory against Magnus very
few people on this planet can say
they've beaten Magnus in any time Patrol
but what does that moment feel like
well it's it's uh it's a moment that I'm
gonna you know tell my grandkids about
and I'm gonna make clear that I got
crushed by Magnus 99 of the time that we
played but just the feeling of beating
the greatest player who's ever lived in
the history of humankind is already
something that I'm gonna hang my hat on
especially because again I wear many
many hats I really I don't study chess
anymore with any kind of regularity and
I think some people kind of expect me to
go toe-to-toe against Magnus and yukara
which was a little bit absurd from my
perspective I'm just happy when I give
them a fight and when you're able to win
a game it gives you a big rush like it
just gives you a lot of confidence and
particularly a game in which I managed
to outplay him which there were only a
couple in this match but uh each one of
them is is something that uh that I'm
gonna remember many years down the line
so it really does mean mean a lot if if
you can get them to to sweat a little
bit
you definitely do make them sweat uh and
you did in this event Donya I have a
question from featured chat we've got uh
username r1p Jack wants to know if you
could play Magnus again in a few hours
what would you do differently if
anything
well I would definitely check uh 1e4 a
little bit more carefully I think I
struggled throughout this tournament uh
in responding to one E4 like I tried
many different openings but it's like
whatever I played Magnus had the perfect
line prepared Knight or if he was
playing G3 and crushing me alakyne he
refrained from the four pawns which I
actually prepared but it's like he had a
sixth sense and he played the most
annoying line so I would
take the prep a little bit more
seriously and other than that I'll be
totally honest I I'm very proud of the
way that I played I I did my absolute
best I was locked in I didn't have the
feeling that I was playing badly I had
the feeling that I was playing to the
absolute best of my ability so the short
answer is nothing I just think Magnus is
a better chess player uh across all time
controls and I'm more than happy to
admit that
you know it's important to be honest we
always appreciate your honesty and I'm
gonna put you on a spot a little bit
here Dania brex Carter go ahead asks who
are you rooting for to win the BCC
who am I no I can't you know I like all
three of these players equally
um I'm equally deferential to them I'm a
commentator I can't I definitely can't
uh reveal anything I just want a good
match honestly uh it would be great if
Reza uh if Reza strikes I I think one
thing that annoyed me a little bit is
how people sometimes in the Chess World
are you know very quick to uh make these
Grand pronouncements about somebody
being washed or somebody being on the
decline and I think alireza has shown
this tournament that he's still alireza
freaking farooja uh so I think it's
going to be a really difficult match for
Magnus he might have to step up his game
even more uh but if he plays the way he
did against me I think we're in for an
absolutely epic fight so I didn't answer
your question as usual Robert but I just
want some good matches yeah at least go
answer my text and we're gonna let you
go so do that also you know you got to
get your prep ready for Alvarez's next
Candace tournament when you play
Marathon bullet sessions but for now
done it's been an absolute treat thank
you so much for stopping by and
congratulations I mean you really
deserve congrats for what was a
fantastic performance throughout the BCC
it's it's been a great privilege to play
in this tournament alongside Magnus and
Hikaru and obviously you Danny Simon did
a an incredible job commentating and I'm
always ready to be back so thanks to
everybody for supporting me throughout
the event I really couldn't have done it
without the wholesomeness of the chess
Community who are always behind me so
all friends and family you know my mom
was watching uh really really helped me
do very very well so thank you everybody
hi Lena oh bye Lena bye Dania
[Laughter]
well Dania nerdiski you know has nothing
to be ashamed of that was a fantastic
performance throughout the bullet Chess
Championship for him but he is
eliminated from the fields we are moving
on to Ali Reza versus Magnus part two
and Danny as we dissect the numbers on
screen here Peak rating in alireza's
favor number of games Ali raises favor
wins by flag and losses by flag about
the same so what's noteworthy to you
here
I was going to highlight not just the
the wins by flagging losses by flag but
the accuracy I mean this is a borderline
coin flip right look at that there's a
reason only Reserve Perugia uh beat
Magnus Carlson before and uh he wants to
do it again right these two guys are are
just
locked in it's a 50 50 match in my
opinion here the the stats say it we
know that the fans are probably not sure
who's gonna take this one I still think
for ruja if he plays the way that he did
a couple days ago when he sent Magnus to
the losers bracket is is the favorite
but I wonder Robert and I want your
opinion on this do you think as the day
goes on
Magnus Carlson gets stronger right
almost like uh you know you think of
Dragon Ball Z right he reaches whatever
9 000 like as the day goes on the fact
that you came from the losers bracket
and are carrying momentum working out
all the Kinks and really just kind of
feeling it might really be in Magnus
Carlson's favor
yeah I think also playing somebody in a
series of games the more games that you
play usually the better it is for Magnus
Carlson because he gets a feel of the
opponent and Magnus I don't think we
could talk about this enough he is back
home now when he played from Barcelona
there are tons of distractions there I
mean he was in the chessboard house they
were having the times of their lives he
wasn't on his typical you mean the chess
Bros are distracting well I think that
they are very entertaining and so Magnus
correctly was like oh they're great
people to talk to and watch and drink
you know cocktails or mocktails with but
I mean in all seriousness we saw the
graphic and with their insights they are
very neck and neck and in that first
match oh there is a one but he won by
three games and he won the first three
games of the match so Magnus if he's
more competitive in the early stages of
this match I think we could see a
different outcome
I agree especially because regardless of
Ali Reza being as Donya called him Ali
Ali freaking farza right
Ali freaking faruzia
um it despite that Magnus Carlsen still
has that edge right that that made him
the goat and got him to be the best
player in the world the highest rated
player in history that I think if he
gets on a roll there's a little bit of a
psychological Factor right where players
can struggle against him because he's
Magnus and so you've really called it
well I think if Magnus gets off to a
good start
maybe maybe this match goes the other
way right and he's the one winning by
three games so I either way at this
point no more speculation needed we have
Jess on the board arugia with a little
bit of an edge here to start game one
yeah although the pawn structure is such
that it looks pretty bad for white and
I'm looking at the clock Magnus up 15
seconds so he was doing this in their
first match he was well ahead in the
clock but what Magnus just showed
against Dania he has the mouse feet at
the end of the game as well so right now
I'm liking magnus's position uh he may
be uh you know actually he's not even
Downing material anymore after he stole
the d-pawn oh whoa a queen sack because
if you take the queen
on we become a c pawn and then become a
new one
yeah that was awesome okay it's still a
50 50 game but as you said Magnus way up
on the clock uh-oh but now things have
turned around and for Rouge has got to
attack Magnus is like unbelievable there
wait no Magnus Magnus turned it around
there I'm sorry I was losing track of
who was who no you're you're fine that's
happens in bullet even for the players
like wait am I am I black in this
position yeah you are oh my goodness
Bishop takes H3 with mate on H2
a brilliant move to start game one with
a little bit of a head Bob whatever
Tunes he's listening to it is working
for Magnus Carlsen yeah that was the
best start you could possibly imagine
and now other reason with the black
pieces look at this opening Advantage
for Magnus he gives I I think in bullet
chess having double isolated pawns is
the worst thing in the world
yeah well I mean even in regular games
double dice are not everyone's favorite
but bullet Jets especially they are they
are things that you wish you could just
like literally give away right because
you'd rather have the open lines the
open files and diagonals and bullet to
give you some tactics so I I agree um uh
Magnus much better in game two you
called it Perugia started out with a 3-0
lead earlier this week if Magnus
reverses that script
you could have Carlson Nakamura in a
final I mean he's just cruising right
now this Knight is going to land on D5
in the near future like right now our
rookie won first okay I don't know if it
matters so much but he brings his name
don't take the bishop because Knight F6
check the queen would still protect the
bishop on C6 Magus he drops the C2 Pawn
though and that gives alireza some new
life
yeah and he's got the bishop here now
one is off the board but still this is
much closer to equal Borussia also
playing faster this game still down on
the clock but not nearly the deficit it
was in game one oh gosh although as I
say that uh oh as I say that it's going
the other way for Rouge is shaking his
head
and again not not calling calling anyone
out in any way but I am calling the
momentum Mount Magnus has already won a
match today he's looking fresh feeling
fresh in his home environment Borussia
looks a little tired just going to be
honest right he doesn't look as uh as
fresh as he did earlier in the week so
we'll see if he can shake off whatever
his uh whatever the fogs are or he's
facing a 3-0 deficit maybe he needs Fabi
to show up and tell him he's looking
fresh because some people are the
recipient of that comment others they
never get it but for faruga it doesn't
matter what we say it matters what he
does and here he is the white pieces and
Danny he's worse once again look at
Black's Army in the center
so good you nailed it on that by the way
so by the way Bobby is looking fresh and
I just want to say that again um all
right yeah the Pawns in the center
pressure on the king you always say
bullet King safety even more relevant
right because you don't have the time to
work yourself out of a bind that's an
important trade there for farushi to get
get some of the tactic out of the way
but look at this Magnus just rolling
still up on the clock again by four
seconds
this is this is a different Magnus
Carlson and we know Nakamura is watching
what are we gonna have here if Magnus
moves on to the final I mean you saw
what the arrows I just drew there's at
some point going to be an attack on the
diagonal going for Queen h2mate like
right now he goes Queen E5 85 right now
but he loud the queen
an inaccuracy for Magnus
for sure for sure that's a huge huge
moment and this might be a huge save
Arusha needs to stop the bleeding you
don't want to fall down 3-0 Magnus
wasn't able to recover from that earlier
he needs to hold this game but Magnus is
slightly ahead in the clock so he should
use as a weapon and honestly I think
Magnus what he should do is avoid losing
that sounds like duh you never want to
lose but you do not want to give I'll
raise that confidence so he's locked the
position up and he's going for a win
oh my gosh look at the pawns look at the
king
Magnus Carlson wants the 3-0 start that
borugia gave him earlier this week
returning the favor
look at this he's also again he's still
cut the king off
yeah that was brilliant with the Rook
and I'm looking at the time but it's
coming down to time oh my gosh it is
blunder apparently but not much time for
either player
there is no time magnusonic King run
wants to flag him but look at farrugia
flexing the better time scramble skills
and die of a match is in the chat what's
up Don you're saying that Max's form is
a hundred times today what it was
yesterday but for ruja just showed off
the mouse speed and that's the annoying
thing when someone has a rook and you
just have a bishop Bishops can't deliver
checks when the king is on the opposite
color the Rooks can just pester you
across the board and the King was cut
off so limited movement for Max's pieces
and I'll raise up better with black in
this game
yeah I love it and it's a really
instructive point for bullet the idea
that The Rook is just an easier piece to
play with there than the bishop the
bishop was constantly worried about
blundering right moving to the wrong
Square The Rook The Rook was in a
dominant spot which allowed for ruji to
pre-move his way back into a Time
Advantage so interesting stuff
um
all right
Magnus still has a game lead but
ferrugia seems to have found it a little
bit
yep I can read between the lines here
what you're saying this game is not the
most interesting bullet game we've seen
today you can hear that in my voice it's
like my voice goes higher when I'm
insecure oh
he buttered the queen
blunder the fork look at look at the Bob
the music
we obviously are going to ask Magnus
what he's listening to No matter how he
finishes on the day
I mean that was actually a potential
match changing blunder because yeah
others up a pawn he was better and there
was no risk in the position except he
fell into a night fork and that happens
in bullet chess watch out for the
knights
note that Magnus didn't walk into the
fork on E2 there with that nice King HQ
move very smart flexing the Rooks
dominance over the night he's gonna take
a 2-0 lead urugu doesn't waste any time
on the clock gets right back at it yeah
three to one in magnus's favor right now
two-point spread as you mentioned and so
we see it's now Carol Khan time and
alireza he's a proponent of the caracon
and this is just a weird opening this
Knight on C6 came from G8 like how do
you explain that to somebody
oh I love that comment from Sarah scribe
what would be spooky is if Magnus said
he wasn't listening to any music
anyway that would be that would be
awesome by the way the chat did say
Magnus Carlson is the favorite here 54
to 46 thanks for voting chat
um we'll see if you're right
I mean what's right is this position for
black like oh what a tactic that Knight
could be captured in two ways but the
Knight was pinned on the diagonal and
then when you captured the queen look at
all of Black's Army and white has a
limited one
and by the way look at E5 what a strong
move to flex the center knowing that you
can't take that ball without opening up
lines for The Rook especially in bullet
you don't want your king to come under
Fire so Magnus
Magnus as Don just said
his form is fire today
oh and look at this H4 move where's the
queen going F6 is next you couldn't play
F6 because the queen was in touch with
G6 now oh he gets the queen into F2
Queen
just missed that you saw his response he
didn't even see queen of two and he
loses the Knight and he's uh
he's feeling the pain right now
I I sorry alireza I didn't see that
either but magnets did and that's all
that's important because Magnus is Curly
out to a three-point lead this is a
complete role reversal of their first
match
yep
yeah we will ask Magnus to share his
playlist he could he'll he'll do that at
some point we'll see if he's willing
um all right yeah Magnus has completely
turned this around
in terms of how he played earlier this
week but borugia still has time if he
can we know what he's capable of here he
goes
Frick's here for black
oh watch out for Queen H4 uh oh Queen H4
what so black has two minor pieces for
rook and a pawn but black has this
Knight entrenched on E3 and it's not
going anywhere unless you trade off and
the next night might be able to replace
it but Magnus fighting well but alereza
quicker on the clock
yep
but this is the kind of game fruition
needed here this is a turnaround he's up
on the clock he's better on the board
this is probably the best game we've
seen him play so far we'll see if he can
convert it
he better I mean don't fall for any
tactics and this these moves for black
have all been good the knight's Wheeling
into E3
yeah this is just great play for all the
Rizzo
yeah up a piece
20 minutes on the clock everyone take a
breath I expect this one to be close
let your breath breathe into your
diaphragm because that sends a message
from your brain that tells your body
it's okay to relax I've learned that
okay wait your brain your brain works oh
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding sorry
I had to I had to I'm sorry
it tells your brain to relax which I
need to do often for my brain
um to remind it to keep working I feel
bad now all right I I just I've got to
be honest I feel bad I'm I feel I feel
great about this I love the roll
reverser here you're hosting you're
roasting you're doing it all I love it
did you just go full Walt Clyde Frasier
on me you know hey
oh God still got a few a few tricks in
the back um all right well Rouge is up a
piece but Magnus likes saying that he's
got a three-game lead he's gonna get as
much time off the clock as he can
um Rouge you know again winning and up
seconds I don't expect this one to go
any other direction but but a farouza
win
yep and hosting and roasting for the
boys
[Laughter]
Magnus looked a little bit bothered by
that defeat and you know he was able to
rebound immediately the last time around
uh but we'll see in this game as he goes
back to what seems to be his trusty
karakan
yeah he's playing the Carroll Khan but
furusia with a better position I think
if this one goes for rouge's way and he
wins two games in a row for the first
time today
uh I don't know that Magnus is going to
keep going back to the carrollcon just
prediction
but this does look pretty awesome for
black I mean the white has these
terrible pawns bad Bishop on G2
all white it was looking better yeah
I've seen better Bishop pairs in my life
yeah yeah some of the moves come in chat
so fast that it you can't keep up right
because they are literally playing at
human speeds that are faster than the
broadcast technology literally like like
we can complain about it but the reality
is they're playing chess faster than
then we can sometimes keep up with
that's just the truth
um we should celebrate it for being
incredible we should celebrate it and
Arusha should celebrate this position
although I'll say this the eval bar
doesn't tell the story of how tricky
this is Magnus has two knights the white
king is open I see Hess nodding along
that always feels good to this low
self-esteem International Master when he
agrees with me so thank you for that
um
and uh okay but you agree right this is
trickier for farugia than the eval Bar
says this is a blunderable spot but I'm
looking at the clock and Magnus is
giving up yeah and the g file yeah H6 by
the way was an awesome move because if
the king took on H6 the queen would have
traded on D2 and that's why Max took the
pawn but he lost the game and now it's
back to a closer matcha here we go he
scored a couple wins there and what is
this from
looking like a
what it wasn't what is it wasn't a bug
Cloud which I'm hoping for anyone who
follows me on Twitter we need a little
little Bond Cloud earlier today but uh
oh Bishop H5 that's an exchange did
Magnus just missed that
he did but you know what's funny about
that is he still has like a ton of
compensation because the bishop can't
move from f8 and now that you've castled
Queen side maybe white can try to drum
up some pressure over there
a nice move F5 forces up assault which
is you gotta Rook you gotta open files
and that's what verusia will need to
flex The Exchange advantage and look at
this he's I mean if if a third win in a
row happens and we are deadlocked at
four you know all your friends we keep
saying it it's Friday take off work it's
already afternoon where most of you are
so let's go
Magnus is doing his best he's trying to
play quickly and just pose a few
problems and he's going after the H7
Pawn if he can trade the king side off
that gives him better chances
yeah he wants to keep the Queens on the
board get something going with an attack
I like Queen E6 look at Perugia
that was amazing geometry
yeah
we always say retreating moves are the
hardest to spot especially with no time
for rusia
put on a clinic here of how to convert
an extra Exchange in bullet and by the
way
okay I was gonna say he's not too down
on the clock he is down four seconds
though
oh
hey
arugia is the future for root Ali
freaking farugia has tied this match
yeah he said hand down man down that's
Checkmate in the corner and that was
sweet from farooch that was an excellent
game he has won three in a row he hit
the turkey if you like bowling
um but look at this position now Magnus
as you said when you've double I say
pawns get rid of them because it opens
up the space for the rest of your pieces
and both players they're playing this
very quickly I such a weird position
yeah this is one that it's hard like
every move looks like a blunder does
Rook C8 not win a piece I mean like I
don't know what's going on here like but
uh the players are are holding their own
especially with uh okay only 15 minutes
left and we are tied even with magnus's
fast start this one is going to come
down to the wire and let's remember fans
you have to win by two in the new BCC
format which I love and uh make sure
that it has us here to the very end I'm
looking at the clock alireza is up
several seconds he's also up a pawn this
is another game that's going otherwise
the first way and he needs to not let up
Knight C5 that one a piece I think oh
but that one's in exchange so he wins
the game Magnus is tilting
yeah he's frustrated he's about to lose
his fourth game in a row we saw him kind
of uh
take a beat and take a breath and then
take a swig of water right sometimes
that's the hardest thing to do in these
online formats Robert is just gather
yourself right because there's no
there's no time to shake off the
emotional effects of of a bad loss and
uh
and Magnus has got to get his head right
here Ali Reza farusia has won four games
in a row if you just joined and
sometimes when you lose a Time scramble
like Magnus did when he had to Bishop
and a bunch of pawns for a rook is you
start getting worried that in future
time scrambles you'll also be the slower
player so that was a huge win in that
game from other reason not just on the
scoreboard but whoa Magnus is giving up
a piece for two Central pawns here
I was about to say great then I was like
is it tilt Magnus sacrifices a piece
from a practical perspective he kind of
likewise chances
even if the engine is saying that black
is better
but look at that oh leaving the tension
pinning the Knight on B3 and so Magnus
passed pawns they gotta start rolling
but this Knight's now going to slide
into E6 to stop the pass deep on
it's the bluff the psac was a bluff the
bones are going nowhere
Magnus Carlson could be losing his fifth
game in a row
he needs oh that was a huge blunder he
let the knights get traded he's lost
yep it's over now and now he needs to
resign and get back at it he needs to
learn the lesson that uh that he gave
that he gave Dania in the last match
don't waste extra time
you can take on F4 take on E5 that's a
winning king of Pawn in the game and
yeah he needs to right the ship right
now because farugia has suddenly been
able to overtake Carlson on the
scoreboard it's a two point farrugia
lead at the moment six to four Magnus up
four to one
yeah
six to four
Magnus Carlson has lost five games in a
row but you're seeing why Ali Reza
farusia is the only other person to win
a bullet Chess Championship title
besides the car Nakamura right this guy
this guy even starting slow something
woke him up whatever it was and uh
he's a monster
he is and he's just playing principal
chess right now but the thing I like
about magnus's very bizarre opening is
that he's up on time so sometimes it's
okay to play Bad moves in bullet as long
as you play those bad moves quickly
yeah the balance of uh don't don't play
so bad that you lose but uh but make
sure you have an edge on the clock when
it matters as I like to say the key to
winning chess games is to play the best
moves fast whoa there's a night on D7
you almost never see that
Rook d8 though what what is the deal I
see two but now you lose a piece
oh Knight F6 check is a big threat
how do you stop that Magnus is and you
see him dejected there he reacts Knight
F6 check is going to be mate with the
Rooks on the D file and Perugia is going
to win his sixth game in a row bullet
it's a it's a game of momentum more than
anything else and farrugia is on fire
right now
this has been exceptional to witness and
farrugia it looked like he was shaky at
the start and he's saying no I'm just
getting warmed up Magnus had that
warm-up against Dunya and now here in
this match it feels like alireza the
worst uh of his chest he got out early
that's really good news he needs to keep
this up though because if Magnus gets
one win you know he smells blood he's
able to win several in a row
yeah Greg shihadi said it it's been a
brutal 10 minutes for Magnus Carlson but
there is still 10 minutes left in the
match so if you can pull it together he
has time
this this is still though looking like a
lot of pressure from Perugia whoa did he
sack oh it was made on G3 that was
glorious that was glorious it was yeah
that's such an easy thing to overlook
and well Magnus has a better Pawn
structure he's playing against these
doubled C pawns but for now all the
reason has more activity until G4
what's going on here D4 might be a move
you don't want to play especially
because he was up on the clock by a
second there was no reason to rush
Magnus getting maybe a little bit
frustrated here
whoa he's gonna trade look at the light
Square dominance what an interesting
spot to be in down a pond but
potentially better in the end game and
it's a big problem why you double pawned
if these one Pawn was in the B file
you'd be able to create a password look
at that move C4 if you take now your
Pawn structure is permanently awful and
now white should just go oh why is he
alive in the king in
before but he was threatened he was
threading Bishop G5 but Borussia should
have taken that chance
and this is actually
a very dangerous game for Magnus because
with time going off the clock you could
lose
you're going to lose a lot of time in
the overall match here Arusha should
play on don't take the draw oh that was
a practical mistake for sure by farugia
but Magnus was up two and a half seconds
so that's why faruja felt compelled to
take that draw so I'm with you that was
a winning end game and he probably felt
that it should be but he looked at his
clock and that's what Magnus did better
he didn't play his best game far from it
and you said it to the beginning of the
show when we looked at dania's accuracy
versus magnus's it's not always
important to play the most accurate
moves because if you're doing it slowly
you're probably gonna get a flag down
the stretch and what is Magnus doing
didn't he just drop the B5 pod
yeah he did and he yelled at himself he
said oh come on man yeah you can see he
said it and uh at least he drew the last
game so he has stopped the bleeding
quote unquote but that was a horrible
blunder
arugia has uh has pushed him perhaps on
tilt here
's a tough opponent for anybody and he's
unbeaten the last seven games is there a
mate no that evil bar was Sky High and
now it's going back down and black
suddenly is playing on the queen side
yeah farouza probably missed some sort
of version of a win there that a pawn is
dangerous
might be might be losing it though okay
what was it oh wait what is it this is
just no it's king D7 but where's the
beef where's the meat I just win the
material
he's having a piece right now
and Magnus is faster look at him he's up
six plus seconds at the moment oh and
the evaluation bar is going down because
you can't keep this E5 pawn and now what
black should do is take the Jeep on if
you could take the Jeep on the chess.com
server says you make a draw so Bishop F3
Play Bishop F3 should be three and it's
a draw he's trying to win find it he's
trying to win
baby doesn't have a choice yeah because
of the match situation but you can't win
this game don't take the Knight that
loses
all right so he is okay now he's really
in trouble
put the pawn on a dark Square though
that was super smart
yeah bending the Bishop from doing
anything but it still should be a draw
well if alarisa can somehow out uh speed
Magnus then there could be a winning
chance but no Magnus is just going to
keep his King in front of the pawn and
we are likely to see any second now and
there's the draw 1.5 that was way closer
than I thought it would be yeah but in a
huge in a huge uh
practical win for Perugia because so
much time came off the clock there are
only six minutes and 50 seconds left and
Magnus is facing a three-game deficit
yeah he's up the pace has Magnus Carlsen
he knows that he needs a win and
probably win quickly he still has enough
time there's six minutes and 40 seconds
remaining in the match so he doesn't
have to go all in just yet but he needs
to get two games wins for him and not
lose anymore
yeah and farugia is just focused I mean
he is uh
he's not he's not giving an inch right
now
he's not and he's going for the good old
mating history what a smart move by
magazine also gets out of this pin so
Bishop G4 will be met by Pond F3
yep
and he goes for it puts the Knight on e4
Magnus turning it around
again as you said there is time but you
have to start winning if you win this
game you've got time to win another
so don't blunder and don't panic
yeah that's really good life advice in
general so everybody out there no
blunder don't panic but but yes
it's really difficult to like keep your
composure and Magnus has been playing
fast but look at that all of a sudden
Ali's he's on the offensive
I would say if there was one difference
right now in the match and I I know it's
not over yet it's farrugia has just had
more pressure against against magnus's
King in most positions he's been the one
attacking the king and from a practical
point of view that has led to some
blunders although right as I say that
Magnus flipping the script on that
queens and knights coming after the King
on G8 oh look at this he wants Knight F6
he and he gets it because he gets Knight
F6 we put the pawn on D6 to interpose
along the sixth Rank and right now
Magnus hasn't stopped worrying about his
clock I'm sorry he's about the position
and worry about the clock he needs to
flag all the Rays here he is up a second
but he's burning clock
oh yeah and I wonder if he had D7 there
but yeah he does have time Knight H6 oh
just Primo D6 the Pieces come off you've
got to remove the Knight it doesn't
matter just you can lose Pieces Just
Beat Faster than your opponent
did he did he blunder that knife for a
second maybe he did no he did look at
that but that's the thing you that's the
right thing to do like Dania has done
this many times you just give away all
your pieces and just pre-move at that
point and he wins on the clock with four
seconds to spare and now it's just a two
point margin
yep yeah it's a really great employee
Robert because at a certain point you do
the math even a pre-move loses a point
second on the clock right that's the
fastest you can play on chess.com is a
0.1 second and so
you know at a certain point you do the
math and all you have to do is free move
to flag your opponent right yeah and and
also when you take a pawn you expect
your opponents pre-move the recapture so
your opponent the per like obviously
took the pawn before he expects magnets
to recapture him before but Max doesn't
so he's not anticipating that he could
take this Knight on C3 next and that
sort of shocks you so I think that you
just pre-moving those situations and now
Magnus he won the last game look at this
position up a few seconds dominating the
queen side with control of the C file
and white is cramped that Bishop on c2's
a glorified Pawn
yeah and remember you have to win by two
so if Magnus wins one more game he's
already in that spot where if time ran
out he would still be the uh
having a Fighter's chance here yes and
he's got a great position right now even
material uh the bishop finally gets out
and it's traded and he wants a pass Pawn
Magnus keeping the lead on the clock
Danny this is a different Magnus than
earlier in the match he's changed his
strategy to just be faster than alireza
yeah playing faster and by the way he's
kind of playing better while playing
faster so right now if he wins this game
and we are back within one uh the uh
the route is not oh but look wow what a
nice trick that Knight is coming into F5
that Rook is running out of squares oh
my God he's holding the Rook with the
King
position King C4 traffic on D3 okay he
gets his Square on F3 it's an ugly
square but here's again Magnus just has
to move it doesn't have to be perfect
chest the evaluation may go into his
favor but just go
just go he takes the Knight wins a piece
for ruja going for tricks but we have a
one point match everybody
call Mom tell her to tune in
mom the meatloaf
I'm watching twitch a chess
oh my goodness it's a one point match
and look at this position both sides
with doubled C pawns and this is a weird
position but I could see an exchange
sack on D5 at the moment
yeah and I can see black not wanting to
take it and playing C6 but okay the
Rooks come off the board B6 is played
some double pawns only a mother could
love for both players doubled C pawns
this is one that almost feels like a
take a breath game for both players
Robert like all right
match has been set the stage has been
set Magnus shows he's not going away
um and uh this one is probably gonna end
peacefully
probably but as I'm looking at the clock
yeah you're right like is Magnus trying
to lock up the position and then he
strikes with that four I would say at
the right moment strike and then F5 and
then things get a little bit complicated
H5 becomes weak You'll Play Knight G2
here probably hold on he does
but at some point F5 comes oh borugia
forces the issue but E5 and F5 who's
getting there that's a huge mistake
oh my gosh up seven seconds and his pass
bonds are mobile whereas his Knight
blocks the enemy pass on this is just
the pawns are pushing up the board and I
think white is taking this game
it's funny the Panic there by farugia
was something we haven't really seen
today but I think he looked at the clock
didn't want Magnus to grind him Robert
whoa was that a mistake how do you break
through if you're Magnus knives
he goes for it six but eight but there's
H2 but Knight D7 and you get your queen
with mate
aha uh-huh oh my gosh it's gonna be a
tied match yeah
and look at ferocious like all right
all right
here we go tide match less than a minute
to play we're going to overtime boys and
girls buckle up it's sudden death
dodgeball but the players better
remember that because it's easy to
forget it's win by two and so you may
get really frustrated you know may get
very emotional but this is not a Do or
Die moment it's not going to be good for
other players to lose but your
tournament run is not over if you do in
fact lose this game
yep
what it what a match of momentum this
has been Robert Magnus up 4-1 farrugia
wins five six games in a row almost
right well and now Magnus turning it
around
what has happened he might be about to
win his what is it well this will be his
fourth game in a row if he wins this
yeah he was down by three and now it's
even so it would be the fourth win and
he's better with the black pieces look
at his uh fluidity and the piece is all
doing something but the bishop B3 that
scares you even if it doesn't actually
threaten anything
nice use of fluidity
all right here we go momentum in this
match is crazy
the uh
it's funny right as I said that
farouja's been the one with most
attacking chances I feel like that
turned around and Magnus has been
putting a little more pressure on white
skiing you said he's been playing faster
that's the consistent thing that's
changed now he's up again
Magnus Carlson has turned this thing
around and now he's bobbing his head to
music again arugia needs to find it and
oh the Rooks trap too so Bishop G4 is
coming
oh my gosh
all right time is out but it's win by
two does farrugia know that he's looking
at the clock
yeah he does he's locked in he does
and this is it if Magnus wins this it's
over
oh my goodness it's overtime it's free
chess don't go anywhere this is exciting
stuff and for Magnus Carlson he has won
four games in a row but right now he's
sacrificed two pawns at the moment he's
playing a Gambit line
playing a Gambit line he's going for it
he wants the kill
in a good spot though the king is out of
the center no longer in danger
what is this Knight F6 and D5 so
okay the but he said no longer in danger
the black king is worse than the white
king even though Black's up a pawn so I
like Magazine's slight lead on the clock
and the fact that he's no longer down
material
yeah and perugia's shaking his head but
again even if he draws this game he's
still in the match so farusha has got to
gather himself keep his Focus so this is
a rook end game essentially with Queens
this should be a draw objectively if the
best chess is played ferruja needs to
play fast and hold on wow what a spot
there by Magnus by the way because Queen
bhacking by Queen like now Max you play
for a win you're up 10 seconds you flag
your opponent
yeah arugia has got to find a way to
trick Magnus here because Magnus is
going to flag him to move on to the
Grand Final and gets knocking more this
is it you got it you got it you gotta
change change what's happening here this
is scary territory for other reason but
we need to keep a count on the 50 move
rule at some point Magnus might need to
play the move F5 even if it's bad just
to try to win on time because right now
Alvarez has Perfect Defense objectively
the opposition is equal
yep and Perugia doing exactly what you
would do in both classical and bullet to
hold this game a master class if he can
hold on yes 13 seconds to make
50 moves basically okay but now he's
gonna Rook F6 and if you're Magnus oh
that's great play from farrugia
wow the defense
the defense from farugia
Magnus loses his opportunity to flag him
and that might be something that comes
back to haunt him if arugia ultimately
turns it around yet earlier in this
competition the first day of action
anishkiri lost a match to Jose Martinez
it went to overtime Anisha was up by one
and he couldn't secure match Victory and
then Jose was able to take over so this
game here if alireza can win it all of a
sudden we're back to a tied match and I
have to say the way that Magnus just
played in that last game it looked
really good it looked promising but then
you get a bit deflated that you didn't
convert
totally agree the psychological Edge has
suddenly shifted back to Perugia here
even though he's down a game I
completely agree if urugia gets this one
and he does have an edge
we've we've seen this match swing wildly
if you're just tuning in where have you
been your mom has been calling saying oh
watch the chess match on Twitch it's
totally lit
now you're here
and uh and for Russia
why did the evaluation bar go so high
there that was surprising
I was just guessing but yeah the queen
had no squares that was nothing but
that's helpful this again the engine
really helps us because you think it's a
normal position and suddenly with one
bad move it's winning for a side and
what is happening here H6 fell but this
past Depot on an open C file who's
better
yeah I I kind of like magnus's chances
here although I will say this farugia
has sped up no longer the deficit on the
time right as I say that
right as I say that gotta play Fast
Magnus is in a position to flag and win
the match uh oh you know what this
reminds me of that candidates game
between Ding and akaru like complete
chaos one side attacking one side with a
past pawn and right now this Pawn looks
very scary and if he gets his Rook to
the first rank he can win this game but
the evaluation's still Level and magnets
up a couple seconds
what and now he's threatening rookie one
I'm like I'm freaking out this could be
the match could be the moment goes but
the bishop was hanging so he had to go
here and now there's Rook A7
seconds to four seconds Here Comes F5 oh
but the Rook was coming to A1 yes you
gotta get checks this could be the match
and if you're olly Brazil if you can get
the Rook off the board it'll blunder it
I was oh my God
oh my gosh
that was the match oh my gosh I was
about to finish my sentence if he can
get the Rook it clears the way to a draw
and Ali Reza he is faster when they just
have a couple seconds on the clock and
that is why he's still alive
but I feel like Magnus panicked there
didn't he have time not to lose the Rook
or no Borussia had gotten the edge on
the clock my God
oh
my goodness what's first doing why did
you spend all that time there
I was gonna say if Roger fighting for
his life but yeah mismanaging the clock
here down by 10 whole seconds that's
like like a peace and bullet although
that Rook might be a trap piece if
you're not careful but look at this he
gives up the exchange to win two pawns
and have a rook on the seventh rank
Magnus he sniffed this out from a while
back yeah that was sneaky that was
sneaky
the only thing I'll say is that Rooks
dude if Rooks get going though in bullet
that's the only thing I'll say
ugh but look at this passers can you
check and play G6
you have to play G6 or just put the
bishop on D3 and get it out of the way
push him yeah he does it I like that
push him baby
yep but Borussia holding on
but the the lead on the clock for Magnus
I think that might even be the worst
part is not only are there two past
pawns supported by Bishop and then the
kicking whoa he resigned seconds early
and farouza leans back and Magnus is
celebrating he knows he's Gonna Take It
oh my God is that it that's it Magnus
moves on to the Grand Final and he's
dancing into a matchup against akara
Nakamura
wow it came to a close so fast and
Magnus Carlson talking to whoever from
our team is uh is enjoying the victory
enjoys the water what a crazy turnaround
what a crazy swinging wild ride that was
for Ali Reza farusia at one point he had
a three-game lead he can't hold on
and he takes third place I feel for him
look at him he's so confused about what
just happened he was winning that match
he had won five games in a row and
Magnus Carlson no longer at the world
champion in classical chess but the
world's rapid and World Blitz champion
and now wants to add the bullet chess
champion to his list of world titles so
Denny that was one of the matches that
you've dreamed to have you know just
it's a privilege to witness and have the
call for it and Magnus Carlson he barely
squeaks by alireza Fusion over time and
I just have to say one more time for Ali
razor like I feel for him he played so
well throughout the match
you steal for him perugia's got 40 000
fans watching between YouTube and twitch
people are here on a Friday this is
awesome though I mean you got it you
gotta applaud for rouge's effort there
and again
felt like he had it but what a crazy
match that was if it was it was a real
wild swing for both players but it shows
what momentum can do for you and Magnus
takes it by two games in overtime
what a match that was and for Magnus
it's already been two great match
victories and his day is not done
because with that win over alireza
farooza Magnus goes up he levitates to
the Grand Final against Hikaru Nakamura
so Danny I mean that was a great match
we're wowed by it but we got to talk
about what's about to happen
yeah no I mean I guess this is the match
that most people want to see whenever
these two guys throw down the internet
tends to stop and tune in the world
tends to stop and tune in when Nakamura
goes up against Carlson I'm gonna say I
think Hikaru is the favorite here again
not just because he's he's won a whole
bunch of these events but I you know hey
Carlos sent ferrugia to the losers
bracket for a reason right won that
match by by four games in the end and
Magnus is gonna have to once again he
had to up his game moving from Dania to
alireza he's gonna need to up his game
again moving from Ali Reza to Nakamura
if he's gonna have a chance here well
I'm not sure if it's good news for
Magnus or not but they up the time limit
45 minutes rather than 35 30 minutes of
bullet when you get back into the Grand
Final so that is going to be on the flip
side of the break but before we do go to
break and hopefully get an interview
just want to shout out that if you've
been wanting to try out chess.com
premium features before committing to a
membership now is the time in honor of
yesterday's International Chess Day cash
in on 30 days premium for free enjoy a
full month of unlimited puzzles lessons
game review and more this offer ends on
July 27th so don't miss your chance use
the command claim in chat to unlock 30
days of premium Now Danny we just saw
some great chess hopefully people get
access to Great features we will not
have an interview but when we return
it's akaru it's Magnus it's the match-up
that the people want and the people are
gonna get be right back
foreign
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
and compete by voting for your predicted
results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
he's thinking about winning when he's
losing and then he's going to demoralize
you when he does that Andrew quickly
winning a couple games in a row that
is really important for him
oh my gosh he allowed a Checkmate as
soon as I said winning a
cup gets it done again just reminds us
off of the bullet world
[Music]
you heard Maurice Ashley say it he
demoralizes you because even when he's
in trouble he still gets the job done
and wins he's a car with Nakamura and
he's a man on a mission and Danny he's
been unbelievable thus far in the BCC
he sure has and obviously uh Magnus
Carlson has been unbelievable today but
now he's running up against the guy who
is unbelievable every day in bullet and
this guy's margin of Victory speaks for
itself there's a reason he's the one
waiting in the Grand Final and uh we'll
see we'll see what Magnus is capable of
against the king of bullet here and uh
I'm ready hey if you uh can't miss when
you're going out for the King right the
wire they taught us that and for Magnus
Carlson he's been the King of Chess for
so long but when it comes to Bullet I
mean Hikaru is just a beast he's a
three-time champ in this event he also
has been just absolutely dominant
throughout this year's bullet Chess
Championship so it's just so so
impressive
yeah and uh you know obviously he's been
watching Magnus today so I think the one
thing Magnus has going for him is in
terms of most recent memory Magnus just
beat Donya he just beat Ali Reza farusha
there's momentum obviously on his side
of the Court here and uh if if Magnus
can get off to a good start and eat that
momentum going maybe maybe that pushes
hicaro off his office form right so I
think that really the beginning of this
match is huge for Magnus and for Hikaru
to show hey I don't have any rust I know
Magnus has been playing but I'm ready to
start off on the right track yeah Magnus
has been playing and pretty much
everything he's played in recently has
been a great success we have some
highlights from magnus's recent success
at the amhs rapid take a look
he blundered his Knight and this is how
it
is
happening oh my gosh it King G5 we found
it oh my God nobody's in trouble Magnus
knows that he just gave you the madness
like not
oh my gosh yeah he's losing right here
loses on the clock and they're finishing
it off in style a Magnus takes it
because it gets him the match Wick tree
what a match performance this has been
by the world number one oh hello
wow Magnus Carlsen with the black pieces
delivers Checkmate oh my God and we have
rapid
Magnus Carlson wins that is a sentence
that we hear very often the five-time
fide classical world champion he gave
away his title he didn't even play ding
the rent became the new world champion
but Magnus he's the rating champion in
the world rapid the world Blitz but his
first foray into the bullet Chess
Championship and Danny he's going right
into the jungle into the lion's den
where he's gonna face off against Hikaru
Nakamura
well you see all those uh those titles
there this isn't officially a bullet
World Championship because we're not
allowed to call it that um but if you
want to call it a bullet Global
Championship you can call it that it's
basically this is who the best bullet
chess player in the world is and Magnus
Carlson has a lot of titles he doesn't
have this one well it is an online game
right and that's the reality right if
you tried to play bullet without
increment over the board
other things happen right so this is
this is it this is Magnus Carlson versus
Sakura Nakamura who is the best bullet
player on the planet and uh I think I
think he wants this title and uh we'll
we'll see remember he has to beat Hikaru
twice right because Hikaru is the one
waiting so you gotta win and then you
gotta win again in overtime and we know
what these two guys are capable of as
far as uh bringing the fans in we see
viewership going up at the break Robert
that's how you know we're in for a treat
people are like stop what you're doing
Morpheus is fighting Neo let's go I do
remember the speed chess championship
between these two it went down to the
wire Magnus won the last game but he was
still one point behind this is a win by
two format so if the time elapses and
you're within a point hey the game the
match continues and as you said Magnus
has to beat hit car twice he needs to
win the 45 minutes in the Grand Final
then he if he wins that he needs to win
30 minutes of the reset so it's gonna be
a tough task you're playing a card
Nakamura he is such a monster he's a
three-time champ of this event and so
far Hikaru has been seemingly
Unstoppable and he looked throughout his
bullet career on chess.com Peak rating
3570 but what's I think most interesting
for me Danny look at how rarely hit car
wins by flag but that might just be
because his opponents resign
yeah that's an interesting stat I I
don't even know what to make of that
because
um you would think he's just as good at
flagging people as someone like Donya
and has played enough games
um to uh to think that that stat might
be higher but yeah maybe it's the Hikaru
factor maybe people resign when they're
losing and he's so fast that they just
see there's no chance so obviously you
see 12 000 games way more than Magnus
but not as much as Daniel noradiski who
played 30 000 games
um and the accuracy is so close between
these two guys so uh what else can you
say right it's a coin flip in many
respects
um I think we both agree Hikaru might be
the slight favorite but I also think
that I speak for a lot of fans and that
I wouldn't be upset if we got a second
round right if Magnus Carlson won the
first and we get more chess because who
wants this thing to end this is amazing
it's so much fun nobody wanted to and
except for hikar he would like to end it
in the first match I just want to say a
day ago if you asked me to make a
prediction I would say that Hikaru was a
sizable favorite Barcelona Magnus much
worse than Norway Magnus the magnets
that we saw today that's phenomenal form
he beat Dania and it was convincing in
the end and Daniel had high praise for
Magnus then Magnus goes on to lose like
six games in a row I can't even remember
it was happening so fast in my memory
I'm like a goldfish I'm like Ted lasso
taught me to be I cannot remember what
just happened but I do remember that
alireza was just blitzing magnets
winning all these games and the Maga
still won the match have you can you
remember a match where someone lost so
many games in a row and still won I was
just gonna say that I think that in some
ways that almost plays in magnus's favor
that he had his back against the wall
and survived right almost even better
Robert than if he had beaten alireza in
a dominant fashion because we know that
you gotta take your punches when it
comes to facing Hikaru you know he's
gonna land a few right hikarnakamura is
going to land some punches because he's
damn good at what he does and the fact
that Magnus is now a little more battle
tested and and survived that that
three-game deficit to Perugia if you're
just tuning in I think that makes him
even more dangerous here against hicaro
in 45 minutes means there's even more
time to kind of recover from a slide if
you have one and for Hikaru he could
have been prepping as you see magnets on
the screen in front of you and a big
question is was that warm-up helpful or
is Magnus potentially tired now and for
Hikaru was resting good for him or was
he not getting into the form that he
needs to be maybe he'll be slow at the
gate what do you think Danny about this
upcoming Final
I mean I think you're you're asking the
right questions right I think that
that'll be that'll be what we see is
Sakura Rusty and Magnus on a roll I
here's what I do think I think the 45
minute extra time we have for the final
which is a pretty cool thing I'm glad
that we did that means that either way
Robert the best bullet Jess is going to
win in the end I think that we might see
some rust from Hikaru you might see you
might see Magnus maybe stumble a little
bit but he'll have enough time to
recover and get himself refocused
although as I say that now I'm like as
the day goes on does momentum become
exhaustion right and that's the risk for
Magnus Carlsen is that he has to win
twice and he's already won two matches
today can he keep it going
as you said he needs to win twice if he
does win the 45 minute match the it
resets and then it's 30 minutes of
bullet chess the winner is crowned the
2023 bullet chess champion they had
twenty thousand dollars and whoever
loses this match still walks away with
16 Grand not a bad prize fund at all a
hundred thousand dollars in total prizes
across the bullet Chess Championship I'm
just excited for them to start I'm gonna
be real I don't want to talk to you
anymore I love you Danny we're super
close friends I just want to watch them
play Hey I'm with you you know what let
no more talk a little more action let's
go by the way speaking of action chat
voted and uh it's even closer than the
other two as it should be 52 percent of
you say Hikaru Nakamura is the favorite
heading into this match again that's
about as close as it can get to a 50-50
split so uh here we go
Nakamura Magnus Carlson
God those words feel good
I certainly do and what is this Mainline
stuff why are they playing a long
theoretical variation where they barely
spend any time and we're on move 21 and
they're trading off all the pieces
and maybe a little bit of nerves maybe
neither side wanted to play
to risk it for the biscuit chess out of
the gate and uh
now Hikaru a little worried about his
back rank that makes sense
and this is seeing more pieces to get
traded
and also from a Time perspective they
played so fast that neither player
should really get into in the kind of
time pressure that leads to blunders
although now things going a little bit
White's Direction
accepts The Rook ending
and interesting he offered a trade but
Magnus doesn't want to trade because the
white king is closer to Center this is
actually instructive stuff you don't say
it often in bullet but destructed to
know he didn't trade because the white
King was more active
yeah
well when two heavy weights meet
sometimes there's a lot of footwork
before you see any real punches landed
and that game was an example of that
just some footwork both guys kind of
being like all right I'm where I want to
be in the Grand Final versus you know
objectively maybe the best opponent I
could be facing I think they both feel
that way and uh a draw starts things off
and now we get a benoni structure from
Black's point of view but the Knight
comes into D4 and the car quickly what
queen b695 Knight F5 a sacrifice
yeah it's it's a bit of a bluff
according to the computer but it doesn't
matter because in bullet can you
calculate everything Hikaru laughs in
the face of danger at the Knight and
takes E4 cold-hearted
but wow there's no mate against this
King It Feels So open
yeah magnus's attack is Raging on
are way down on the clock here by the
way yeah good call
so what's happening here black is I have
two minor pieces
every piece is hanging and apparently
that's no good because queen of six at
the end I think
we find F6 the queen is under under Fire
yeah so now this Queen's under attack
and the rook in the corner a white king
is safer between the two but black is up
a full piece
dude these guys ability to just stare
down the barrel of
of insanity is is what separates them
right I mean I said coldhearted really
it's cold-blooded hikaru's ability to
navigate those tactics and and Parry
that those threats Robert good try by
Magnus though
but this queen on C1 covers the G5
Square which is very important right
there the queen would have went out to
G5 with a Perpetual instead of the queen
on C1 covers the king escapes Hikaru
Nakamura should take this game
yeah he's finding a way to get surgical
against that white king but Magnus
holding on
is there a Perpetual now and hikara
needs to be careful because if Magnus
was Quincy 6 check he can't pre-move he
would lose his Queen that's a draw by
repetition yeah is it
shakes his head couldn't find a way out
of the checks Magnus snatches a draw
from the jaws of defeat there
wow yeah a car is probably a bit unhappy
about that he was up major material uh
but Magnus he's showing off the mouse
speed now he is improving I think the
more games he plays the faster he gets
in crunch time
yeah he's he's uh keeping up the speed
that's been the one thing you wonder if
he was going to be able to do he did it
with Dania did it with alireza well he
maintains feet against Hikaru this game
this game is down five seconds
and Hikaru also
looking pretty good he just win the
exchange for free I think he did that's
that's easy money right he's up upon
right now and he's pushing his pawns
this is a knight in Bishop as this just
doesn't look good for black but if
anyone can weasel their way out it feels
like Magnus he's good at these end games
E3 and C4 yeah sorry it wasn't exchange
it was upon I was hallucinating there
but ultimately white is still just much
better
uh and the fact that Hikaru was also up
what is that 14 seconds on the clock
in fact Magnus just resigns and just
like that we have our first decisive
game of the match at Kara Nakamura with
a one-game lead yeah Magnus says I
cannot look at that position anymore you
outplayed me good work and now it's back
to the drawing board and the openings I
feel like we haven't seen anything of
note thus far they're dabbling in
different lines but you know sometimes
we know we're gonna get a Berlin match
or we're gonna see one side out prep the
other it's just a bunch of jockeying
right now
agree but I will say the one thing we
also haven't seen is sometimes Hikaru
will play the the I'll call him the
dubious Hikaru specials right where
he'll play the B3 stuff or play the
openings he knows objectively aren't
great
um because he's so comfortable with them
and he knows he can he can outplay
people anyway I don't think he's messing
around with kind of dubious openings
against Magnus Robert I think that's one
thing we've seen
and although that was a mistake for Matt
apparently it was almost winning for him
and now suddenly black is the side for
Choice black is the bishop pair and
isn't losing material please take me
says Magnus I want to hit both your
Rooks and the car says absolutely not
I think it's just like that with no time
I just
I don't know
um
Magnus for like the fifth time today is
sacrifice in exchange in a great way
like look at this position he has a
bishop and two pawns for Rook he also is
the healthier King his oh he connects
four I win
well I'll say the other thing he has is
an edge on the clock for the first time
although right as we say that he
blunders or is there some sort of mate
it's mate G5 is coming in its mate hey
Carl has the sack and then his Pawn
should go just push the F Pawn E5
oh but then there's yeah he gets behind
the pawn first and then he chases it
down that was well played good technique
five extra seconds on the clock for
Magnus
yeah Hikaru takes one of the pawns but
it's not enough Freddy he's gonna get
frisky on the f file and uh
and Magnus is going to level things up
in this game unless something wild
happens he also has a huge Edge on the
clock which I think was maybe the
biggest turnaround of all Robert in this
game Magnus was leading on the clock
wire to wire and did you see that Magnus
went King E3 he gave up his Pawn so it
was objectively a bad move but he's
playing faster and the car expected the
pawn to push so he pre-moved his Rook up
and that's why Magnus was able to steal
that rook and the game so it's two to
two and that means we are Level once
more just like at the start and look
again they're playing a quiet line
almost as if they're playing each other
in a classical match
yeah agreed this is high level opening
chess quiet lines and uh you know
there's 40 now just under 40 minutes on
the clock so
we got a lot of Chess here we've got 55
000 of you tuning in across all
platforms don't go anywhere the fun has
just begun on this Friday
I don't know if we're gonna get overtime
chess but we're gonna get a an epic
Clash no matter what well Hikaru is
going to get a pawn up Advantage because
he just stole one of those double
isolated Pawns in the center but White's
Pawn structure not healthy but who cares
how healthy it is when you're up two of
them
yeah a couple of doubled but past
e-pawns feels good
they call a rebounding here from that
loss he just had if you can if he oh and
then yeah and by the way again look at
the edge of the clock this has been an
interesting match so far Robert it feels
like
the decisive games at least I know we
had a couple draws the decisive games
have been very one-sided right likes
once one player is not just winning on
the board they're dominating on the
clock and the other guy has to go back
to the drawing board Magnus just resigns
yeah you're right 100 right and also
they're switching off who has the lead
on the clock in some earlier matches one
player always Jets out to a huge time
advantage and then the other player
catches up here they're trading off
victories they're trading off time
advantages and they're also switching up
their openings I mean Magnus he did play
this style in the game that he won two
ago and hikara says if you're gonna go
for this again I'm ready and I'm
stealing a pawn in the center
yeah agreed by the way that that boat I
had earlier there were 5 000 votes from
the YouTube chat which which was 52
Hikaru Nakamura but then we have several
thousand from twitch and it's 58 Hikaru
Nakamura so interesting both twitch and
YouTube slightly favoring Hikaru in this
match and Hikaru again to be favored in
this position yeah because Rook D5 was
such a superb move there by Hikaru and
Magnus he's only down one pawn and he's
trading off Queen side pawns if he can
trade off the remaining Queens at pawns
he has a draw but Hikaru he's too smart
to do that he brings his King in and
that should be that when his King and
Rook pressure the C2 bomb
yeah although Magnus still making it
tricky this is this was awkward
this is awkward I okay can you just take
G2 no because C4 check would have won
The Rook that's right wow what a weird
turnaround there Here Comes Magnus with
a c pawn and the clock is even which
means that mistakes might happen but the
B Pawn they're both queening but you win
the house for for black here and that
means that Hikaru has the upper hand and
I think we'll see our first two point
margin
That's The Confident nod followed by the
duck lips clip it and ship it everybody
the first hikaranakamura facial
expression we can easily catalog like
this
he likes it oh Danny I miss compensating
with you so I'm glad uh we got the
hikara facial reader with us today but a
car is a beast I think no matter what
his face tells us his play tells us that
he is just
desperate to win this event not because
he's not the better player but just
because he really wants his title oh yep
oh and something happened there there
was a blunder
it was 904 check possible for Magnus I
think first no before before he brought
the question okay
ah Knight F4 and then Queen and you win
you win the night with check okay Agnes
Magnus misplays that you can't miss
opportunities like that against Hikaru
as we said he's the king when it comes
to this format and you don't get many
chances to swing at him so Magnus missed
an opportunity there we're of course
lucky because we have the Ebel bar I
mean again no
no shaming and saying that that's the
truth but uh but yeah if this one ends
in a draw Hikaru maintains his two-game
lead
and it's very even but Hikaru is up a
few seconds so uh black is more active
pieces but hey Cara has more time with
white and this bishop now is terrible
it's locked in here that might have been
a bad decision but the Knight also is
stuck both pieces can't move yeah what
is going on with this position you've
got okay I think akaro just settles on
the oh okay yeah that's literally a draw
for as well
um that was funny it was Mutual traffic
takes me back to Hikaru on ICC beating
the Bots he would get positions just
like this close it down and then flag
the butts but here Magnus was repeating
enough times we see some you know the
smile there and it draws a fair result
but a good one for Hikaru keeps his lead
yep it's funny because I think a lot of
people just don't appreciate some of
these skills Hikaru has were these
aren't accidental these were these were
trained we always do okay Carter was
raised on ICC right and he was a human
who was beating Bots when Bots were
first entering the online chess servers
and and he he figured out strategies to
be computers which is is really
mind-blowing when you think about it and
um that's one of the reasons he is so
resourceful so pesky and tricky on on
on the online formats and this position
I have to say at first glance it looks
really good for white uh the black king
feels less safe than the white king and
the bishop is out but the king slid to
the corner and now the black king is
being hunted
yeah Magnus well it's a victory he needs
to turn it around bring him back within
a game
looks like he's on Pace he Kara gives
the head shake
not over yet but Magnus should get this
one Black's King is wide open you just
got to figure out a way to break through
if your Magnus
yeah Queen D5 Queen D7 looks like a good
way to do just that and oh can you take
it he doesn't bring the queen in
I think white can bring the queen to F7
and then push this Pawn
yeah the car trying to make things oh
you got Queen G1 C1 Queen outside chance
of Perpetual
that was the queen oh
yeah
he sees it the second time
that's pretty funny
oh gosh he you know he waves his hand
what was I doing
anyway hikaru's streaming of course you
saw that delayed reaction that was
pretty funny
didn't see the queen
and it's a one-point match once again
Danny and Hikaru going to again one of
these quiet positions so these two have
been engaging in combat in the end game
yeah protest Gambit declined I love that
decline the rare the very rarely cited
botesque Gambit declined there
um but okay if Magnus wins this one
Robert then we will be level with 30
minutes like a regular match right
remember we had 45 minutes to start this
this final uh so we get extra chess
between these two guys which is great
but if Magnus wins it basically is a
wash and we're back to 30 minutes with
the tide match what is happening the
eval bar is doing push-ups over there
going up and down and it seems like
there's an incredible amount of tension
what is yeah
how does this survive for hikar the
king's getting checked but there's
there's no rookie three I'm like looks
like peace okay rookie three comes I
takes the rook and it's a car who's on
the prowl
wow
and the H Pawn is running Harry for the
win
and by the way a flex on the clock in
this game by hikar look at that that is
a massive time Advantage bullet and
Bishop E4 was a great move there by
Hikaru he knew to trade pieces off
because their ensuing end game would be
so nice for him he gets that win and I
think Magnus was blinded both by the
sunlight and by hikara's great moves
yeah Magnus needs to get a little help
with the curtains and uh get a little
help on the board right now with Hikaru
Nakamura taking a two-game lead as we
reach the 30 minute Mark and uh he's on
four I guess he's answering the question
that he isn't Rusty despite having
watched Magnus for the last two hours
he's ready to now play Magnus and did
you make an unintentional Greg shahadi
ICC reference by talking about curtains
if you want to throw back to ICC
usernames we can do some trivia which is
fun shout out to Hawkeye we miss we miss
uh we missed that guy
um but uh
yeah anyway curtains
uh this looks pretty nice for black
there's a great light Square Bishop for
one sign and a not so great light Square
Bishop for the other and the black king
is also more active
yeah Black Ink finds the nice E5 Square
even though yeah he goes for the bishop
ending
not a position that white should be able
to win especially when you're the one
down six seconds on the clock so Hikaru
continuing
to do what he does and pull it
a lot of time left though we got tons of
time
oh he's trying to trick him I was like
how could you give this access point but
there's Bishop A2 check and Bishop
26 would have been lost
these guys are full of Tricks silly
rabbits tricks are for kids although not
in bullet chess
for everyone in bullet this bishop is on
the best possible Square it's keeping
the king out of both directions but that
was smart by Hikaru he trades some pawns
the 50 move rule starts once again and
unless Magnus can take both these pawns
he is going to lose this game on the
clock yeah
what you gotta do yeah I wonder how good
these guys are in bullet compared to my
accuracy score in classical guts if I
had to guess they're better at bullet
than I am a classical test just saying
like this is insane
and look at Magnus so what hikari's
gonna do is put his Bishop on the I
think on G6 at some point and he's yeah
he's gonna take the bishop and then yeah
he did it
and the pre-move or the win just as long
as you don't accidentally stalemate or
repeat a position three times Magnus
shakes his head knows that Hikaru got
the better of the the metabolic game
there and that's the third time that a
car has done that he beat alarisa fuja
twice in that same exact end game with
bishop and wrong corner for The Rook
pawn and now Hikaru has built his lead
up and in addition to his three-point
lead he's got a really nice position in
this game with the uncompromised pawn
structure on the king side for white and
blacks kingside and shambles
yeah and now you see the difference in
body language hikara with the head Bob
feeling that ABBA Dancing Queen
okay that's what he's listening to by
the way sure
um
the car just on the prowl right now dude
look at this
up a piece
up a piece about to go up four games in
the match up four seconds on the clock
Magnus no longer bobbing his head to
t-swift someone needs to change the
momentum for Mr Carlson the only good
news that I can think of for Magnus is
he lost six games in a row against Ali
Reza and he still won the match Hikaru
is next level right that is the final
boss but he has lost a series of games
then was able to go on a winning streak
of his own so that at least should give
him some confidence in the back of his
mind
yeah agreed that's the point we were
making at the start of the match is that
because Magnus was down against all the
residents and came back that has to pay
dividends here at least from a
psychological perspective if you're if
you didn't see that match Magnus was
down three games Robert with five
minutes to go
like yes he was winning the game to make
it too but that was that was impressive
and he ended up really turning around so
Magnus is not going to go quietly into
the night here no of course not he
always is a fighter and now we're
getting to end gaming hikaru's actually
been out playing Magnus in many of these
end games he's aided by the clock he has
a slight lead in this game as well but
look at the peace placement he goes for
C5
yep and the car was just feeling he's
really flexing it right now enjoying the
two I don't know maybe that's maybe that
is an Ava because that doesn't look like
a dancing queen bee no it looks uh
hmm I wonder what he's like listening to
I was gonna just throw out a random
musician but I I will ask him when it's
done
he's trying to listen to anything all
right the beat of his movie yeah again
the creepy thing would be that he's not
listening to any music oh my God and
Magnus blunders a piece tomorrow
maybe gonna take another one
and you know we we asked a question
would hikaro be rusty because Magnus is
the one who played two matches Robert
but the other flip side was Will
magnus's momentum turned into exhaustion
and if this one gets away from him I
think I think at this point it just
might be that uh kind of ran out of
steam here against the final boss as you
said
just unreal play thus far from icaro
he's fast he's playing very accurately
and he's getting to the end games where
he can play for two results as we say in
classical chess he knows that if Magnus
plays Super quickly he might hold a draw
but otherwise Hikaru can use the clock
as the main weapon
according to one of our mods Magnus
Hikaru was listening to some Bollywood
Hits
by the way if you haven't seen RR
fantastic film sorry back to the test
Donna pause it I just watched it the
other night
you know everyone wants to be beam out
there
foreign
okay we can't turn this into a movie
podcast all right so staying on the
chest here Hikaru Harry's was a lot of
pressure but Magnus still has an edge
with the bishop pair so also the biggest
note is that he's not that down on the
clock right it's very close I think
that's huge for Magnus to keep the speed
up
yeah and look at this end game it is
even material two Bishops against Bishop
Knight pair and Magnus should be better
but I'm not sure he trusts himself that
he might even look at this position one
that in the back of his head he wants to
win but at the same time he's like I
don't want to lose on time
yeah
you don't want to lose on time but uh
you also don't want to lose on the board
at this point I don't think Magnus is in
danger of losing on the board
but can he create enough for a win you
got to start racking up some dubs here
down by five and
the pawns trading off is really good
news for the night right the night is a
slow moving piece the Bishops they look
across the board in a better way E5 is
dropping but then A3 would be captured
so uh yeah I was desperately Clinging On
to both of his Pawns
yeah he's trying to create some sort of
Swindle he does manage to steal one but
Hikaru
wait okay
there's some chances to win here and
time is even enough that Magnus could
convert this
now I think what Magnus could have done
was take this Pawn you go to Bishop E6
and took it I'm worth it I'm getting
flagged and he takes the pawn right now
yeah
hey there you go there you go
a draw
apparently
icaro has crossed lines that very few
should Venture into he's listening to
Nickelback
whoa look at this Photograph Danny every
time I do it makes me laugh
although I will say why does Nickelback
get so much hate what is the deal with
Nickelback getting all the hate I don't
know but all the answer that we all want
is like what was on Joey's head
what the hell was on Joey said
where I grew up you know yeah
the I grew up watching these two in some
ways online not really I'm an old man
but uh that's how I there are some
people growing up watching these guys
it's true and uh as we get back to the
chest white is up a pawn it's a Magnus
needs to show that Magnus technique and
he brings his King all the way up
but he's dropping pawns and I'm worried
about him losing another game
yeah the Knight is just so pesky there
the king is in a in a danger zone for
sure there are mating net possibilities
although look at the aggression I like
this F5
if we're traded Into The Rook ending
uh well Carl's fine sorry yeah he does
well it was actually doing fine I mean
Magus needs to be reminded of who he
really is you know he's going to the end
game it needs to be reminded of who he
really is
um
can just take on D7 and he doesn't
realize it yeah they go D7 and King d8
and it's over now he stops to calculate
I think he's not wait whatever no no he
realized that he was winning because
he's on a delay because he's streaming
so he's like I could have just captured
his rook and won the end game
oh it was Perpetual okay I didn't
realize that they
that it was a draw yeah but he just
realized he was winning if he had traded
Rooks
oh this looks really bad for Hikaru
though like I know Hikaru sometimes
plays some dodgy stuff but handing your
opponent the light squares in front of
your king
feels like a bad idea usually
arrow is foreign
maybe he'll make it as a poor man
stealing although right now Magnus is
going to steal one
Danny okay that game reminds us of who
Magnus Carlson is this is how you remind
us Magnus
of who you really are
yeah I don't know if I want to keep
going in this which I can like I
can if you want
um you can post it all day this is we
should I wonder if one day we'll confess
how many times you and I have played the
game where we were sneaking words on the
show because our producers don't want to
know that but every once in a while
Talent has to uh you know
we won't go there but every once in a
while we have fun I mean Danny come on
let's be real someday somehow I'm gonna
make it all right but not right now
okay make it all right right now because
he's down a lot in the match but he's
better in this position because he's
going right after hikaru's King
yeah he is although he's still down five
games oh though I feel like he just won
didn't that make it four maybe I missed
something
um well I think we missed a lot because
we were singing We were you know stuck
in
in the Nickelback references which is uh
you know never go full Nickelback as
they say
I agree with that chat that hey Cara is
so good he's been playing Amazing chess
but in this game look at hikaru's King
it's wide open and Magnus isn't even
down any material for this attack
yeah Magnus is rolling here
and it is a four game it is a four gun
I'm glad that even when I lose my focus
cold Nickelback I was I was uh on top of
the score there Magnus should bring this
to three games unless something crazy
happens although I'm not going to doubt
those nights this is
this is this is uh
okay he's doing a good job cleaning up
the tactics no more Forks push him baby
and uh Magnus brings us to sleeves here
no no Magnus is slow right now he's down
to six seconds really he should get this
done but he's playing very slowly
yeah Hikaru is removing the bleep out of
this okay but that was good seconds that
was really nice by Magnus there uh to
push this F Pawn get his King involved
and not fall for a fork so Magnus it's
back to three points he's feeling better
you can see it on his face but Hikaru
still has a healthy lead in the match
18 minutes to go remember we had 45
minutes to start which ultimately is
huge for Magnus because at this point if
it was 30 minutes probably would be down
and out right so this is um this is
exactly what we what we uh wanted to see
the most chest possible between these
two guys in a final
and uh Magnus is uh turning the momentum
around
yeah I mean Magus is asking could you
say goodbye to yesterday because If
Today Was Your Last Day you gotta win
this bullets
yeah
you are Shameless you're Shameless
oh well back to the uh to the bullet
here it looks like Magnus with the black
pieces he's much better because his King
is safer and he's going after hikaru's
Pawns
yeah and if A2 Falls this is one of the
positions that it's it's it's hard to
lose as black that's the other problem
is that Magnus is up on the clock and
there aren't any tricks right sometimes
you're losing but there you know there's
weirdness to come there's Knife Works
there's King safety in this position the
uh the game is a pretty easy one for
black to play yeah you're up a pawn and
a clear extra one here's Bishop C he
wants the outermost Pawn bring the king
over to E8 and play Bishop d8 I think
that's what oh again with the a pawn for
the d-pawn but that was a surprising
decision
yeah
I yeah I don't know that that improves
his winning chances so right as I say
that maybe Hikaru is in a position to
hold this that would be
unfortunate or Magnus for his momentum
to come to a screeching halt and by the
way a car will up enough on the clock
that that
this could get dangerous yes it really
could and now you see both players
scrambling at the moment and look at
that defense from a car he plants his
Bishop in front of the pond and now he's
the one with the active king and a
passer of his own
what is going on there
Queen ending invited seven seconds for
Magnus 10 for Hikaru
and Magnus wants to trade Queens but not
at that point no he didn't want trade
Queens right there
oh wait what was winning if you took
because some weird opposition you know
the king the white king D6 and King C8
white was winning yeah
dude that's crazy though that's two end
games Hikaru has missed the chance to
trade into a winning King and pawn
ending and again we don't have time you
know this is not the most instructive
Chef show you're ever going to watch on
Twitch everyone uh because it's bullet
but yeah white was winning due to
irregular flanking opposition there and
uh
crazy stuff
yeah that was pretty wild and it's hard
to trade like that because your king is
so far away you think I might lose the
game and that is definitely not
something that a car wants and you know
what he's doing he is waiting he doesn't
go down to one second left and then make
bishop H6 it will be a three-time
repetition the game will be a draw but
at least he burns 30 more seconds off
the match clock
yeah and he's pausing to make sure he
does that
um and playing The Meta game taking a
sip of that giant mug of water
there's not really much to do here
looking at this analysis every time I do
it makes me laugh every time I do it
make me
I can't do it anymore dude I'm trying to
wean off the Nickelback references
because otherwise I'm going to burn it
to the ground
I'm sorry I was slow for the update
there reading chat and that laugh was
probably a little unnecessary I'm so
glad it's the weekend
um
all right well the draw the draw comes
to akaranakamura he has a 10-7 lead
well uh we'll switch that scoreboard
here in just a second but yeah that draw
earns some time off the clock and
um
and Hikaru Nakamura maintaining his lead
yeah he's really playing a great match
but Magnus is making it more and more
competitive not just by the scoreboard
but just the way Magnus is played in
many of these games but I like what
hakar is doing here look at how even
this position is and it's a complete
draw and that allows Hikaru to burn even
more time off the clock because he's not
going to lose this game and Magnus you
know if he doesn't play quickly at some
point a car may say I'm not making a
draw anymore I'm gonna try to flag you
yeah but I'm just furious right now with
our mods who did a poll for the best
Nickelback song where's photograph oh
photographs at the top agreeing because
I missed it yeah photograph there you go
photograph is is probably their best
song
yeah of course it is
yeah
another another king upon ending Hikaru
going to get as much time off the
as he can although I will say this at
this point the meta of getting time off
the clock isn't that relevant yet right
this is not the type of lead Robert that
is devastating it's a three-game lead
remember if it even gets within one game
we have overtime chess because the new
rules are that you have to win bullet
matches by two so I'm just pointing out
that regardless of the fact that we're
losing time here I I don't think that
he's in a position to really protect the
lead like that yet yeah it takes me back
to hikar versus Wesley so and those
speeches championships where they did
this forever it felt like because there
was increment which made it worse
because you could make a little pawn
move at some point and then start over
again uh in pure bullet with zero
seconds added per move yeah someone's
gonna uh flag they can't just wait
forever so the 50 move rule happened and
now we see in this game Magnus he's
going for it he is on the offensive on
the king side but has he overextended
a nice strike by Hikaru to play F5
that's actually a really thematic
instructive point I know we said we
don't get a lot of analysis and bullet
everybody but that was a really great
thing because white has also opened his
King with the spawn storm and that's
what black points out with this F5 move
so Hikaru makes it spicy and both kings
are in danger
what's going on here the queen went up
to C4 black blocked it is there trouble
on this E6 square if you can TR you just
dropped the pawn on E6
didn't didn't Magnus have there was a
knight on E6 he could have taken this
Pawn on D6 so Magnus with the oversight
and now Hikaru I mean he looks like he's
getting a knight F3 in there
yeah
wow
the car turned that around consider it
done as far as Nickelback Nickelback
references in an interview consider it
done maybe we'll do that all of us are
in the inside joke oh
you have two Knight takes E2
yeah that look at the time Hikaru was
kind of burning some of the clock and
then he made that move and it was a
rough decision and Magnus when Bishop G5
allowing this he had better options but
he just wants to make a draw he does not
want to lose on time he's supposed to
grab these last Pawns
yeah he's only got six seconds
keeps a pawn he has winning chances but
Magnus will have none of it that one got
away from Hikaru and again I know we've
seen Hikaru doing more of the meta
bullet things here milking the clock
protecting a lead but with 11 minutes
plus to go here
you know we already saw Magnus overcome
a three-game deficit in five minutes
versus Ali Reza ferrugia so this is this
is close
I'm totally with you I think that Hikaru
is trying to use that strategy to his
Advantage but in some of these games
it's his disadvantage you'd rather win a
game in 20 seconds than draw a game in a
minute there's still enough time for
Magnus to make this comeback and look at
this position it's very sharp where
white has an extra Pawn or did have an
extra Pawn over there on the queen side
now black is in the driver seat D5 is
that's a weakness and whoa that was a
quick spot by Magnus
yeah yeah
he's gonna have a couple extra pawns
here plus the bishop versus knight
Dynamics should be better for black only
thing you have to watch out for usually
is the time against Chicago but Magnus
also up five seconds on the clock here
so a good turnaround
or Carlson
uh oh yeah but that open King Hikaru is
not gonna make this easy spying some
tactic
three just fell and now it looks like
we're into an end game that unfortunate
for Magnus should be a draw but now look
at the clock Magnus is the one up a few
seconds he's also up a pawn he should
try to win this game
you should and now he's got to pass the
epon this is a lot harder to hold than
it looks for white if Magnus can uh
can keep his cool on the clock he is
still up three seconds that's huge
yeah this is not easy
King this is up to F5 oh also E3 is
subjectively now it's objectively losing
for white Magnus in position to bring
this back to two games
oh but he kind of tricked him a Hikaru
tricked him when the Rook is in front
the king could come back to the second
rank but if the The Rook wasn't back
there there was gonna be an E1 Checker
now his car is going up on time oh my
goodness and he's the one who could win
on the board I mean okay it's gonna be a
draw but I wonder if he shouldn't have
traded Rooks there that's crazy
wow
wow what a save
that was incredible he understood that
if his Rook was behind upon which you
normally want he couldn't get his King
back so he drops The Rook to the first
rank brings it in front of the pawn and
his King was able to Scamper back just
in the Nickelback of time so that was a
nice save there for a hikara Nakamura
and and now we have another game that's
Mainline stuff
uh
and yeah we're gonna do the game chat
where all of us are on this inside joke
and Robert and I are going to try to
squeeze Nickelback references into the
interview and it'll be awesome it's
gonna be fun
um I don't know who we're gonna be
interviewing we still got a long ways to
go
I will say that again I know it's a
three-game lead but hey Carlos had his
chances Robert objectively I think to
make the lead bigger we know we missed
those spots in a couple of end games
right where he didn't convert to the
king upon ending so
will it come back to haunt him right now
Magnus again threatening to make it a
two-game lead yeah he's should be
winning this I don't see how you stop
this Pawn unless you give up your rook
in A7 right now who cares about this
bishop you're getting this queen Magnus
he wins a quick game there it's only a
two-point spread that's huge that's huge
exactly no this is uh
again I think that I it's it's too early
to provide criticism overall in any sort
of match strategy but I do think Hikaru
protected his lead a little bit with a
couple of those draws and Magnus saved
Magnus held on and now might have a
little bit of momentum as we head into
the final minutes
and now we have another complicated
opening where uh black is attacking the
queen side and also White's not
attacking anywhere because the Rook on
C8 keeps White's pieces honest
yeah we need to as a nice little trick
he goes and steals that pawn
whoa But Here Comes Carlson on the
second rank
is there
takes an F4 so he missed something
better I don't know what it was but it
cleared the Eva bar instead of being all
the way down for black it went back
towards the middle and somehow a car was
escaping
how
yeah I don't know how Hikaru escaped
that that and now now it's turning
around the other way 93
he blundered the end game he always got
an extra Pawn on the outside
no this is just great for a car in fact
he's winning I think if I'm Magnus I
might just resign
wow
oh and as soon as I say that a car
blunders the pawn
our blender's right back
what's the time 28 to 18 seconds so
Hikaru oh F6 check he pre-moved it
hicaro played King E5 and Magnus had
pre-moved F6 the house Falls with the E6
pawn and what a huge win for Hikaru that
is to keep magnus's momentum back and
you could just see the pain in magnus's
face as they get into another end game
no Queens on the board in this one uh
seems to be the match strategy for these
Players let's go down to the end game
white has the bishop pair but we'll see
if Magnus is still reeling from that
loss he needed to hold that game but he
still does have enough time to get a
couple wins here
what is this position Danny this just
looks really good for magnets to my eyes
in the eval bar is absolutely unfazed
yeah
looks great for white but it's also a
closed position that could go for a
while here the z-file being the only
open one so it's I'm starting to play
the metagame Robert I'm looking at the
time again Magnus did overcome three
games in five minutes for Borussia but
Nakamura is a different animal and uh
you're starting to get up against it
where the closed positions are are ones
you just have to avoid even if you're
better but now black is better and the
pushes his Pawn so maybe some trades
will happen opposite colored Bishops
there's a check on D5 here sorry why is
black better because the B Pawn is just
that strong
you're asking me you know
eval Bar Needs a raise now that is a pun
I could get behind right there
um
okay Magnus finds a way to get the
counter play
unfortunately though it this is a draw
that's going to take another 30 seconds
off the total game clock for sure the
car is going to milk this all the way to
the end and we're going to be under five
minutes
and if you're a car I don't think you
push the beep on you might just lose
that end game as black will be up a
piece but white will have these past
pawns that will roll up the board so
Magnus needs to go like King G5 back to
F5 back and forth over there and Hikaru
might yeah he goes in he goes in for the
win he goes he goes for it
wait the car's down down time he's
losing
oh F4
and here remember
Magnus just needs to move it doesn't
matter if you blunder what a huge
momentum shift here F6 and he said oh my
gosh
what a momentum shift
Magnus Carlson wins to bring this within
two games and we have four minutes and
45 seconds left I spoke too soon I
thought I thought it was a dead obstacle
Bishop ending Hikaru should have taken
the draw and then a car brought his King
in he could have repeated at any moment
and he saw the Grimace on his face that
was one of those I shouldn't have done
that why did I do it and speaking of why
is it doing things what is this opening
for white it looks really bad
yeah
this is where Hikaru is
you've got to take a breath and not go
into the the kind of dubious opening
Lane that again sometimes he can revert
to which works against 99.99 of people
in bullet but Magnus is going to get
positions like this and be better if it
can't replace those weird openings just
light Square domination you can't kick
that whoa a queen sack on G4
wow wow he made that actually so quickly
it looks pretty good yeah that that was
that was ridiculous that might be one of
the most ridiculous moments of the match
he's losing the game though yeah
he's losing the game now it's falling
apart and that King is in a lot of
danger what a move there G5 by the way
forcing The Rook to the awkward square
and this is gonna be a one-game match
with three minutes to go everybody
buckle up
you're looking at a couple of rock stars
where the chest comes easy and the
blunders are cheap
Danny I thought you were saving me from
all the Nickelback references and then
what what wait wait one third and and it
seems like Magus could have taken more
advantage of it but didn't but still he
has the better position and the safer
King a knight into D5 the bishop slicing
across the board a long range piece
against the black king
yeah the momentum again we've seen it
happen Magnus overcame momentum against
Borussia very similar to this down three
games with about five minutes left now
he's only down by one and uh you gotta
win by two thanks for everything you
just said Captain Obvious of your walk I
do appreciate it but you know what I
would do if I'm hikar here I'm looking
at the overall match clock but it's only
a one point spread look to flag Magnus
Bishops are more difficult to move than
Rooks in time scrambles mag is doing the
right thing pushing his Pawn all over
the board it's a bishop and three pawns
for a rook and yet here I am saying look
at the clock and look at ikaro's chances
yeah
yeah objectively the chess is good for
white here but the Rook is so much
easier to play in these spots the bishop
is stuck you can't pre-move like look at
this The Rook can already pre-move in a
way that white cannot and that's such a
practical advantage in these games but
he's going hey he's going for the age he
goes for it but he had to take time on
it yeah he's moving very slowly in akaro
playing book oh a repetition I don't
think that's good for Hikaru I felt like
he could have played on
yeah yeah I think he should have played
King E5 there instead of the last Rook
A5 and allowed the game to go on now
now you're down to a game though that it
could be it right if Hikaru wins this
game
that's it Magnus got a win to send us
into overtime or at least not lose
and what is this opening it looks very
adventurous and White's King is safely
castled Black's King remains in the
center but black does have the pair of
Bishops so I would say initial Advantage
white but if the Checkmate attack
doesn't happen quickly then black
suddenly might be right back in this
agreed F6 it's a spicy move
and you want that Knight on D5 but he
wants more than just a trade
wow Rook enters the center But Here
Comes Bishop E3 but Brook D3 oh he
walked into it oh
yeah check I missed the check oh
everybody missed the check I mean we're
in scary territory this queen just
wrapped around a B5 but it's doing
nothing over there in fact the E4 Pawn
is about to drop and the F6 part is also
weak in the end game
no one knows what's going on here least
of all the eval bar it's a five second
time Advantage though for Hikaru which
is huge if things stay the same Magnus
has got to make something happen or he's
gonna get flagged yes if Magnus is going
to lose he better keep an eye on the
match clock and then resign immediately
because there's still time left and he
would have a chance to win that game but
oh it's getting bad for him it looks
like the Evo bar is saying white is
better
that's a brilliant point if Magnus is
going to lose he needs to resign like
like now yes but it's unclear you know
this position looks like black is the
one who's doing well he's stealing the
pawns but his clock is down under 11
seconds he's grabbing all the pawns he's
got to go he has to rush this like he's
never rushed before
yep 10 seconds here comes the A4 match
it's a tie match and they get one more
game God I think there were seconds on
the clock so this game doesn't start the
sixth move
um mini match that they would have to
see who can win by two uh we'll get word
from our producers but he went Rook
before I'm not sure if he was going for
a cheeky you know my opponent my pretty
move or he mounts it but either way
Magnus takes the game and we are knotted
up at 13 and a half
OMGs or snaps there's a reason those
emotes exist for subscribers emotes like
this because we freak out when bullet
chess happens and this is uh
this is crazy and Hikaru again
just felt like he he snatched a defeat
snatched a draw there from the from the
jaws of Victory he he and Magnus has got
to get credit for keeping in those games
by the way Magnus now up on the clock
here
this is a renewed sense of faith in his
ability to win this match and while we
are seeing some trades the H4 Pawn is
loose that Bishop on G7 hitting the E5
Pawn but I think Magnus with the lead on
the clock and I would take his position
even though that Rook just landed in the
enemy camp
completely agreed you gotta like White's
position here this is this is regulation
we have had it confirmed We Believe by
production and game Ops who are behind
the scenes making sure well
Rook left I guess there was
ah there's something here apparently
there is he goes Queen do you think he
wants rookie with a mating attack the
queen blocks and she said yeah
there was Queen takes F3 there for Black
by the way everyone that's why he
retreated to D3 Hikaru trying to get the
Queens off the board who's better here
with the Apon the Eep I have no idea
what's going on well Magnus just settle
on a draw no I think he does and you see
Magnus he's mad at himself because he
was up about seven seconds the match
remains tied now we are into overtime
and so this it changes things it's we
still win by two and they get six games
so after the sixth game if there's
someone in the lead they win the match
even if it's just a one point margin
Denny this is what the people wanted
this is what the people wanted it's what
they signed up for I am uh I am just
sitting here like a little kid
just bundled up on Christmas opening
presents knows that all of them were
going to be great doesn't matter I don't
even know what's going on or any other
holiday
I'm excited hey you like to open
presents I think Magnus wants to open
the C file this Rook would have caused
some problems but he doesn't do that
instead he gives himself Foursquare and
goes to the bifa and watch out the A2
Pawn is hey rugby two
oh my God that's nasty if you take it
we're gonna have a baby girl Brittany on
B1 you can't give black oh my God it's
all falling apart here
ikoro will be down in the match by the
way
for the first time today if he loses
Hikaru has not trailed in this match
wait what what did Max's Queen just go
he didn't Retreat it he could have
brought it back to F7 but he goes for
this and maybe we spoke too soon
what just happened
oh my gosh this F6 Pawn is handed
how did that happen
and he pre-moved King h8 and he's just
losing the game
wow
well
I gave a commentator's curse earlier
and it backfired on Hikaru Nakamura I
guess I just cursed Magnus there because
I am shocked that Hikaru Nakamura has
won that game
drop his Queen back when he was stealing
all the Pawns in the position maybe he
just didn't realize there's a bishop on
B3 before that he didn't realize he
could go back but that's a thing of the
past and right now Magnus with the white
pieces has a nice position but he's down
five seconds so he needs to go after
this D6 Pawn he needs a hammer away at
Hikaru setup did he just oh he got so
fortunate oh my God it was loose so so
lucky he blundered the skewer but it
didn't matter
they are worse in this position but as
you said up a few seconds on the clock
but again it's win or go home literally
if anyone earns a two-point margin
everybody that's it ship it we're done
and what is happening here The Rook B3
the steals a pawn but this open C file
watch out for the black king
oh they're making mistakes both though
of course it's bullet it happens yeah
well there's apparently a winning Queen
67 free night
free 97 it was just hanging oh it's
still hanging oh he sees it the third
time
oh my gosh
agreed these games never disappoint
oh my gosh hey Carlo on a little bit of
a delay that's the moment where his
Knight was hanging
and now Bishop is hanging it's not over
though oh you just dropped a second
piece so he first up then a bishop and
his Queen's not trapped but look at
Magnus just get those Queens off the
board and then oh he didn't even have to
a car resigned
yeah
the car throws in the towel
we're back to tide
all netted up in 15 games a piece moving
on to our third game in overtime
everybody
I haven't seen in overtime this good
since UConn Syracuse back in that big
East tournament this is really some epic
stuff I mean they must both be super
nervous at this stage and look at Magnus
adopting this french-like structure
without a light Square Bishop
yeah good for black here Magnus
increasing his space advantage on the
queen Side High Level chess and bullet
look at this move King D7 by the way oh
connecting the Rooks
it's a great end game that's what they
say right I hate on the French in the
opening but when you get to the end game
it's almost always better for black
because the base Pawn F7 very hard to
get to and look at White's pawns they're
sticking out a bit yep yep opposite
position you want to be in in a French
also no Edge on the clock this time for
Hikaru he is staring down what could be
his first deficit in the match and the
last time you said it you jinx Magnus
this time you almost did as well
apparently but look at that these
Knights they're going right after this
rook and if Rook C2
what is happening here I have no idea
he's gonna take C1 and be down the
exchange but he's got some compensation
he wants to trade them all he wants to
trade before he's gonna take everything
off the board Ricardo doesn't want it
and his car is a huge trouble Magnus
just has to take why did he spend like
five seconds on that turn he's wasting
time
yeah now he's losing the C pawn and he
doesn't even win the material back
this is going the wrong direction for
hikar for Magnus okay but he did go up a
piece here
and wow
Knight F5 go give a check just give a
check somewhere what's the time oh but
you got 10 to 7 Seconds here and it's
now under super dangerous for Magnus
yeah he's pre-moving he's trying his
best oh he's blowing the A5 pawn and now
the car is taking it and he's taking the
G6 pause it the Rooks come off oh my God
White's even better now oh my gosh
and Matt has lost the time
wow
he screams at the screen unbelievable
I don't know what he's yelling about but
that is not what you wanted Hikaru
maintains a one-game lead or regains a
one-game lead and Magnus has never LED
in this match
and I think part of it is your fault the
commentator's curse strikes again oh
shut up I mean no you do the talking hey
we're not rooting every time every time
Magnus gets close to taking his first
lead again to just joining Hikaru has
led this match wire to wire Magnus
completed at one point what was it a
four was it five games at one point
uh it balloons up to quite a substantial
difference between them but I guess
they're chatting maybe Hikaru because
his matches haven't been close he
doesn't know that overtime is still a
win by two ah they're checking to see
what game they are so that is very smart
uh that is really smart by both of them
they're seeing how many games do we have
left before it becomes sudden death
yeah
yeah so they're chatting with the team
uh staff confirmed it was five games of
a lead for Hikaru Nakamura at one point
in fact at a couple different points
Hikaru had a five game lead so we are in
overtime chess here both players
confirming where the match sits
it's a win by two scenario unless we get
to six games and then it's sudden death
whoever wins is your bullet chess
champion although actually if Magnus
Carlson wins we get more chess so for
the content many people rooting for
Magnus for the uh for the Hikaru fans
they don't want to see any more chefs
and who do you think that little stall
favorite because Magnus lost the game
but both players must be nervous so do
you feel like any side gets the upper
hand thanks to that mini break
I think with players like this who are
just objectively so good it probably
doesn't really matter
um
but you have to believe it always favors
the person who lost the game to be able
to take a breath so maybe Magnus can
kind of control his uh his emotions for
a moment he is up he is up a little bit
in terms of space here
oh and that D6 Pawn is the worst Pawn on
the board if you can get around your
dark Square Bishop so yeah a little bit
extra space for Magnus but a lot of
extra time for Hikaru five seconds at
the moment
and whoa what just happened what just
happened there I look away for a second
and it's like vacuumed off the board
yeah everything just exited Hikaru
probably okay with its raw even though
that doesn't win the match because he's
black gives him another chance to win
with white remember win by two unless we
get to get to Seven to the seventh game
this is an incredibly played game thus
far Danny I've been watching the evil
bar it hasn't moved they put all the
best moves to this point and black gives
up on peace but gets a bunch of Pawns
and it's gonna be a draw by Perpetual
check
maybe not but this car should play for a
win look at the clock
he should he should and he knows it and
he does it Hikaru going in away there
was a blunder maybe six yeah this part
is promoting he allowed the queen in the
pot you see it on magnus's face he knows
it's over oh my God and that
and that does it is Nakamura defended
his bullet just championship title oh my
goodness that was a Clash of Titans and
Icarus speaking to his fans his audience
on his stream but Magnus you know he's
as disappointed there with a second
place finish but Hikaru he didn't
Trail a single time in the match and
Magnus almost made it happen but almost
is not good enough
a wire to wire victory for the reigning
bullet chess champion Magnus Carlson
will not get one of the only titles in
chess that has evaded him at this point
in his career
Nakamura is still
the bullet chess champion
still again fourth time bullet chess
champion and look at that final score
17-15 we had free chess we had overtime
and for Magnus you gotta give him credit
for that comeback he was trailing
throughout the match he almost took a
lead
but he couldn't just make it work he in
the time scrambles Hikaru was simply
better
wow what a thriller kind of weird how it
ended there with the players confirming
the score I I I mean but it all happened
so fast in the end Hikaru Nakamura does
what he's done most of his career which
is out speed outplay out battle people
and bullet and he is still the uh the
bullet again World chess champion if you
want to call it that is not World D-Day
relax but you get it
what a crazy what a crazy day we just
had and well it's been a crazy day it's
been a crazy week but it's over our
bracket will not change from here there
there are no nobody else uh joining the
competition nobody else left standing
besides Hikaru Nakamura so it's all over
Hikaru Nakamura is your champion and so
with that I think we are gonna take a
break leave your questions in the chat
because when we return Danny and I will
be joined by none other than your bullet
chess champion Hikaru Nakamura
did you teach uh certain positions or
openings or middle games or what what is
that you're what is your training uh
people look like I'll give you one of
the secrets here so a good a good coach
will correct your moves but a great
coach will correct your thinking
and um all right hold on hold on I want
to repeat that again for the people in
the back can you just repeat that again
so a good coach will correct your moves
and a great coach will correct your
thinking so really part of the magic of
coaching is holding a mirror up to a
child's so they can see their own
thinking
and sometimes you made the move because
you were overconfidence uh you were
dismissive of your opponent and so these
whether they were this kind of
self-knowledge the self-awareness is
part of the cognitive process and it
helps to accelerate the alert and curve
as as players
um and so meaning games in that loss
because you didn't know who Roy Lopez
you know the 14th move of the Roy Lopez
or because you couldn't execute a rook
and pawn that and yes of course these
attack these are technical things that
you need to win chess games but games
also lost because of lack of
self-knowledge so
um
the issue of spasticity losing super
Trojan uh you know and I tell the story
many times waspassky lost the world
championships have chosen in
1966. it's basically goes back to
baffinic and he says you know why did
why did I lose now uh people many people
may not know but spaski was an
incredibly talented chess player right
in many ways he's considered one of the
first Universal chess player he can
attack like Tao and he can defend like
the Trojan but he loses this match and
Buffet told him uh the great talented
Boris basket uh did you study Patrol
right so meaning it wasn't he didn't
think it was important to study the
opponent the famous line from Sun Tzu
know your enemy know yourself and the
Thousand battles you you will never lose
uh heathus thought it was about about
sebasket
and so he had to take the time and
recognize that he needed to understand
petrosion beating you means I must
understand you chess is a conversation
is a dialogue between the two chess
players so by 1969 he knew what to
expect at the chessboard he has he has
studied uh Petrosian and he eventually
becomes uh the 10th uh world champion
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and we are back just about ready to
interview your champion of the 2023
bullet Chess Championship Hikaru
Nakamura as I said before the break the
bracket it's set in stone nothing will
change and the name that will be written
in the history books as the winner is
akara Nakamura
he got the job done wow was that a wild
ride Robert yeah he holds on at one
point with a five-game lead Magnus
Carlson comes storming back wins by two
in overtime
I could say a lot more but I think we're
just gonna look at the bracket and see
how he got the job done Robert yeah the
the final name does the talking Hikaru
Nakamura he talks and while playing
chess at the highest level and he's
about to talk to uh so Hikaru we welcome
you into the show huge congratulations
how are you feeling now that you just
took down Magnus Carlson
yeah I mean it was a crazy match
obviously at some points I thought I had
the match under control I mean I think
there was this there were many many
games were back and forth but I think
pretty consistent consistently I was the
one who was ahead on the clock and
because of that I was really pressing
and Magus found some amazing resources
uh there were probably two or three
games when I was up I want to say like
three or four where I thought it was GG
and um he kept hanging and there was
that one game where I was up by three
the bishop ending and then I tried to
win it like I told myself I was gonna
make the draw with the opposite colored
Bishops I went for it and then it kind
of went downhill
um but nonetheless uh it was just I
think really really exciting for the
fans I'm glad that I found a way to keep
it keep it together at the very end
is it hard to keep your emotions
together when you know there were games
like that or like the bishop ending
there was that one game that maybe you
could have traded Brooks and been
winning in the king of Pawn ending which
you realized after and if your opponent
makes a comeback are those are those
games kind of calling at you and
distracting you or are you able to
forget them and just stay focused in the
moment
well I mean there's one very important
thing which is that uh for better or
worse I've lost a bunch of games against
Magus where he's he's pulled these
Shenanigans he finds ways to to win
games that he should never win let alone
draw and so I've had a lot of experience
of being on the wrong end of those games
and um so I think having had those
experience it certainly helps a lot in
terms of uh not like not like going over
the top and losing your mind
um I mean Magnus does it better than
anyone else like even when I think about
my games against alirez or others like
they aren't able to find ways to uh to
survive losing positions when they get
the good positions they do things but
they're losing positions where they can
turn around it doesn't happen that often
and um I mean the fact that Magnus did
that just with all the experience I was
able to just keep going I think more
more than that um the mindset that I had
um there was there was also a game where
I think I I blundered I was just getting
I was down like it was Queen of reverse
queen with the past E Pawn I think or
d-pawn whichever pawn it was
um and I just said keep going keep
making moves and that was sort of the
emblematic of the spirit I had which is
once the game ended you just keep moving
forward just keep keep trying to play
moves um and I seem to do it quite well
and I think I think that was the main
thing is I just I really mastered the
tempo um and I was able to just keep
moving quickly and Magnus I mean he just
wasn't able to be as precise and in some
of the critical games
well on that note Hikaru it seemed like
many of the games were taken to the end
game quite quickly some early Queen
trades was that part of your pre-match
preparation you don't you know no more
opponents to face you can let us know
what your prep was
yeah I mean I think that um Magnus going
into going into the end games was a huge
mistake um actually now I can say this
too I there were a couple games against
Ali Rez as well where I felt like um
when he was ahead by maybe two or maybe
it was three games or like two or three
games with a black piece I think where I
got these quick end games I was able to
just get into the Rhythm move really
quickly and I felt for Magnus was a huge
mistake going to the end game so I think
in general I was just quicker than him
and it's not as though Magnus can't
outplay me obviously I mean he is one of
the greatest if not the greatest end
game players of all time but I I felt
that the end games that we're getting in
the moves were too easy for me it was a
situation where I'm trying to think of a
good analogy I guess I'll use American
football as the analogy but um you know
in American football they're too tight
they're like they're running backs and
one type of running is what we call
downhill running where basically you
just run right into the linebackers how
do you go straight into them the other
ones where you Juke you try to go side
to side all that other stuff and um very
much I felt like it was very downhill
where my moves were just instant I could
make the moves insulin it's like going
right into the game you don't have to
think there's none of this fan Nancy
schmancy but you go right into the game
and um I thought it was a huge mistake
for Magus to go into the end games as
much as he did I also thought Magus
didn't vary the openings enough I got
too many of these positions that were
similar to my match against Joss from
earlier because Jasmine also plays E4 D4
Knight F3 Bishop D3 C3 and um same thing
happened today where so many games I got
like the first 15 20 moves without
having to think and then I was just
quicker than Magnus so I I would say
those were going to the end games and
then the the lack of variety especially
with the white pieces were probably his
two mistakes but obviously it still
could have gone either way even at the
end um Magnus just he wasn't able to
keep together in those final two games
and um I mean I just just found a way
amazing stuff Hikaru this is your fourth
bullet Chess Championship I think I
think you've also won a whole lot of of
speeches championships but one thing
that's been different in these last two
events is you beat Magnus Carlson in the
final and obviously we know that the uh
there's a lot going on in the world of
online chess right and so having the
opportunity to play Magnus is that does
that make these a little bit sweeter
getting getting Magnus in in these
events that you haven't beaten him
before does that make this title a
little bit more important than even the
previous one
yeah I I mean I I I don't want to
downplay because of course if I say what
everyone knows what I want to say people
are gonna be mad and and everything so I
guess what I would say in general terms
is that uh you know when I look at
playing Magus is always a great great
pleasure to play against the best player
in the world I think for me
um I I feel like I can compete with him
on equal terms I think I've proven that
action over the last year so but more
more importantly and beyond that I think
the the thing that a lot of people don't
understand and the thing that really
does separate Magnus besides the fact
that he's just a beast and plays such
great chess um it's a psychological grip
that he has or psychological Edge I mean
if you looked at his match against Ali
Reza olly Rose was so close to winning
and it seemed like he was going to win
that match Magnus was able mentally to
keep it together better than Ali Reza
was he's able to win those games at the
end and snatch that Victory away from
alireza I think Daniel was actually
quite similar Daniel had some good
positions very early once he missed like
one or two opportunities boom it just
all went downhill instantly and um so I
mean I I feel like it's a lot of it is
in the mind and I I think I said this
before but as far as bullet goes I think
that if I keep it together and I just
like I don't get inside my own head uh I
can play with anybody and I think I've
proved that especially against the best
player in the world the last few times
yeah you certainly have proven against
any opponent that comes your way and I
guess a question I have for you is are
there any people out there even in this
field that you see room for improvement
from them or any up and comers that you
think will be challenging for BCC titles
in the future
um I mean I I think uh Ollie Reza
obviously is a big question mark I think
you know when I look at Ollie Reza uh
whether it's bullet or Blitz or Raptor
clasp I mean I think there's probably
some some mental things that he needs to
work out I think if he works those out I
mean the sky really is the limit for him
um I mean Magus magnus's Magnus I mean I
don't even know how you say Magnus can
improve because he's obviously so
ridiculously good already
um but I I think that if I was looking
at any player it'd probably be Ali Reza
maybe even Daniel if Daniel could
actually stop uh stop being so afraid of
Magnus and myself I I mean maybe I
shouldn't say that but I do get the
sense that with Daniel I I think he he
also can play completely on par with
Magus and myself but but the problem is
is that he uh is that I feel like in
critical moments he starts worrying he
starts respecting us too much he expects
us to just blow him away and I think um
yeah I would say all the Resident Daniel
are probably the two players who I mean
if they could sort some of those mental
Kinks out there I mean they very easily
could win against both of us I I think I
think it's selling it's really selling
selling them short to act as though they
had no chance
yo
one player missing is nihal sarin what
do you think about him if he if he joins
the field how does he stack up yeah I
mean Neil actually I forgot about Neo
he's the one player who I believe was
invited and Decline and everybody's
wondering why uh why he didn't play I
mean obviously I had no idea why he
chose not to I think that you know it's
been a while since I played him in that
SEC match but he always performs very
well I know that when I think about
players that I've played online
um he is the other player who's very
very pesky very annoying somehow he
keeps finding resources and keeps the
games going uh definitely someone to
watch
um I would say actually more so than any
other player near the top in in recent
times he's very very reminiscent of
myself
um very very reminiscent very good at
Blitz very good at bullet plays online
all the time much like I used to when I
was in like the mid 2600s and um I mean
I think at some point he's going to be
able to turn on classical chess but I
think he's another player that has great
chances in all the online formats if
he's able to uh if he's able to to play
I don't know why he couldn't play but he
he is he is the one player who's kind of
we don't know where he's at but he he
could get up there
yeah we of course would love to see
nihal play in future editions and he's
always invited so he just needs to
accept uh but we have accepted a few
questions from the chat so uh the first
featured chat question I want to ask you
is from fuisan Geno who says Hikaru how
did you regain yourself after having a
strong lead and Magnus being able to tie
up the match
well I mean I think the main thing is
that I just like I was in this Zone
where I wasn't even thinking about
anything kind of I mean I mean there was
one moment that it that it bothered me
um which was basically uh when I lost
that Bishop the Bishops of opposite
color ending where I tried to go King C3
or no I tried to go to F2 and win the
g2h3 pawns um that was the one moment
where I did look at the clock uh around
the time where I could have made an easy
repetition and um and I didn't that's
where I felt like I thought for brief
second there I had the match one that
was the one moment when I when I let the
situation kind of get in my head a
little bit but other after that
um it was it was more just like start
the neck team just pound or pound or
Blitz out whatever adjective you want to
use um to get those moves on the board
as quickly as possible and then once
you're in the game the time sitting down
you don't have time to to think about
anything else and I think that was the
most important thing is that like the
star of the openness I was able to Blitz
out like 10 or 15 moves and I had no
issues doing that um so it was more that
because it was bullet and I I could make
all those moves so quickly I never
really had such thoughts about them
about or it's a verb whatever same thing
um but but yeah you guys get the point
that was great honestly this is we've
got more featured chat here but it's a
great interview so I want to keep
stealing questions on my own I'm gonna
try to combine one so this is a question
from Johnny baker27 which he asked what
changed for you from the past when you
used to have a tough time against Magnus
and now you beat him and I'm gonna kind
of build on that again with
um the psychological Edge that that
again as you said maybe used to exist or
does exist for Magnus in a lot of ways
wasn't there even though you watched
Magnus played really well today right he
returned to Norway he was on a roll he
beat Dania and alireza was there a part
of you that was kind of looking at
Magnus and worried about his form and
and why do you does he not have the same
psychological Edge over you anymore if
he used to
well I mean there are a few reasons I I
have no Ambitions in In classical chess
anymore I have no Ambitions period in
shots I'm a streamer first
um so that that's the most obvious point
A lot of people are going to make more
jokes and memes about it but at the end
of the day like if I think about it from
like Alex's perspective I mean obviously
I don't know for sure this is his
perspective but you know back when I was
playing chess all the time playing top
turns there's really only one goal you
have in mind and that is try to get into
the Canada's tournament if you can get
there then you know the chips will fall
where they may that's obviously uh very
much a coin flip or a roulette table
when you're playing in such an event
because anything can happen frankly but
it's like get to that tournament maybe
get to world championship so that's
really the only thing you can think
about and the hardest part is that with
Magnus always there playing such insane
chess you're always worried about him
then you see him play all these games
like you see what he did against all the
rest of today against Daniel the way you
stormed back against me and you it's
just it's very easy to just sort of stop
thinking of him as a human it really is
like you some of these things that he
does on the board you just sometimes you
don't understand it I mean there are
many examples from my own games against
him that I could that I could use and I
think the fact that I don't have such
thoughts anymore I don't really worry
about about trying to become world
champion or trying to get to number one
I mean these things are just like gravy
on on top of the mashed potatoes as we
like to say uh here in the South
um so I think for me it's just like I
just play I have fun and also I have to
add separately though I think for Magnus
one of the perhaps I don't want to say
mistakes but I think he's watched he
watched a lot of my streams during the
heart of the pandemic and I think when
you watch my streams it also sometimes
makes me seem better at chess than I
actually am too because I'm explaining
all these things all these deep Concepts
and I think that also might play some
role as well so I don't know if I
completely answered your question but uh
I mean I I think it's just I I don't
care I just play have fun whatever
happens happens that nothing changes in
my world um you know I can become world
champion I'll still be a streamer first
Nothing's Gonna Change so no no pressure
no worries no stress in life and I'm
sure there's some psychological some
psychology inspiration thing that video
that someone's done on this exact thing
but um it is what it is
well well I mean you know it's always
good to hear you tell it like it is and
you say you don't feel the pressure but
it does sometimes feel like you know
you're still just improving almost and I
guess a question from the chat that's
related to this from Sahar Malik is what
is your best advice to get better at
bullet chess because Magnus did seem to
be an improved version of himself in
that final match and you Rose to the
occasion
I mean bullet is so hard I mean honestly
I feel like bullet I would say for
anybody who's not like 2600 plus just
play it for fun don't think about
improving just just play it because you
want to play it that that's really all
that I think I can say I mean I would
say if you're above that I use like knee
Hall as an example of somebody where
he's placed all the time online I think
if you're if you're trying to improve a
bowl you should play as much you can
online if you have the time
um but again most of us don't have that
don't have the time to play bull like 10
12 hours every day but I was lucky that
um that that you know back when I was
younger I did used to play like I I had
these great matches and again like I can
only just now now I'm one of the old
guys I'm not one of the young guys
anymore I remember you know when I was
like 12 13 14 on the internet chess club
I had played this Marathon like five six
hour matches with guys like uh Hawkeye
uh that German general and Schmaltz and
like I mean I was fortunate to have that
opportunity so I think you just have to
play as much as you humanly can uh if
you have the opportunity and you know
also it's funny because my openings
against Ali Reza and Magnus today were
very much in the spirit of my childhood
openings the opening that I learned from
my stepfather but then also that I
played online all the time and many of
those bowl games there's always E4
Knight C3 and then like Grand Prix
attack play like the the Austrian attack
against Hawkeye I mean all those all
those great uh great openings so
um I think if you have the time just
play as much as you can
today was a throwback we mentioned
curtains earlier we mentioned the year
of the rabbit we mentioned Hawkeye this
is how you remind us of who we really
are that's a Nickelback reference hey
Karu Nickelback
what's the best what about Nickelback
that song that's Nickelback song I don't
listen to Nickelback come on no actually
you know I did want to say one thing uh
I don't know which song was on my
playlist but there was there's one great
song during this match which really got
me grooving there was this like this
Indian song I I don't even know I'm sure
people in chat will know what it is but
there there's this Indian song which I
started singing to which was like the
best thing ever it was Chaya chai I
think it was like that was like the
greatest thing ever that really that
really helped me just get get grooving
um because I think at that time I was
ahead but that really got me into it so
um the I mean the Indian songs are great
and no wonder uh no wonder all these
Indian players are so good they should
be so inspired by their by their music
Hollywood
man hey Carl we never want this event to
end we don't really want this interview
to end but we will let you keep grooving
uh on your stream congratulations once
more this was such a fantastic
performance by you
thank you so much you guys have a great
one
awesome can't wait for next year yeah
man
seriously I already can't wait for next
year's event I literally can't wait for
the next year's bullet championship
nobody can wait can we just instead of
having a next year's can we have like a
next month we just do it next week wait
wait doesn't bull brawl happen tomorrow
we're all the best players including
Hikaru Dania Jose Martinez Magnus Tang
Etc don't they just go and play that
it's uh that's a great call-out yeah
bullet brawl tomorrow on Saturdays and
every Saturday forevermore it's the uh
Saturday title Tuesday for those who
didn't know what happens best players in
the world playing bullet tomorrow if you
want more action
well great interview there and um we got
another great interview around the
corner here
yeah we're about to get Magnus Carlsen
in for an interview you know even in
loss he still comes on to Magnus uh if
you can hear us for joining and Sergeant
go your way
yeah can you hear me as well
yeah we got you
okay good
Magnus like Robert said thanks for
joining us even though it didn't go your
way let me just ask the question right
off the bat where do you if you had to
play this match over again is there
anything you would have done differently
where did you feel the edge slightly
went to Hikaru
it's hard to say
um I felt that at the start
you know the first couple of games uh he
was out playing me uh completely and
then it was still pretty close and then
there was a stretch where he he was
building up Elite and I was like
so the thing is that
I've played
uh I played some Bullets Over over the
years uh not that much
um specifically on on tesla.com but I I
played like over the years and but the
thing is I never played Hikaru and I've
seen
cinecaro Crush everybody else
uh
and even in this tournament but I always
kind of
I always kind of thought that I matched
up decently with
um with him and that um
sir sort of my main strength I think
which is also his main strength is that
we're simply
better at chess than the others and so
we can make good moves more quickly so
they need to to spend time but then yeah
at some point like he was playing he was
playing a lot faster than I was and he
was playing much better seeing all kinds
of tactics and that was a massive
reality check for me I was uh at that
point I was thinking oh uh okay so he's
just that much better than than I am
um uh I was like yeah fair enough uh
this guy's just a beast I think
um I think he was feeling the flow at
that point uh and um
I think it was the same as with alvareza
like I was losing a bunch of games in a
row I just like to get that one for one
draw one win to stop the bleeding I
think he became a bit more
um defensive at a certain point that
then I actually had chances which I
didn't really think I I would at some
point but I I yeah what I just want to
say is I'm I'm extremely I'm extremely
impressed uh I I mean I always knew that
he was
that it was that it was good
um I always thought that he was somewhat
better than I was at bullet but that he
was like this much better I didn't
didn't realize and
yeah it's uh it's insanely impressive
and Magnus that's extremely high Praise
of coming from you of all people but the
match was tied at 15 and then he won the
last two so it was a level match and I
guess
on that note like how did you improve
your play uh over time you're back home
do you think that made a big difference
or what was it about today where you
elevated your game
back home like that just meant that I
saw the I have a better setup and
I'm gonna be I'm I'm I mean I'm still on
Fast and scrambles but I would be like a
little bit faster like I could actually
make they may not be good moves but I'm
actually like able to make quick
pre-moves which I just wasn't the last
the last few days and I I think
um
I mean I I said I said before the
tournament that I thought
um
were much better than the others um
uh well except except for me I thought I
could compete with them and I still sort
of think that uh I still think that
Alvarez has like a little bit
better than than I am but yeah your car
is
very strong and yeah I I could have
uh I could have won the match for sure
but um
yeah I wouldn't have felt like I beat
like that it would be just natural I I
mean at no point in the match did I
really feel
uh I feel Superior that's all
wow this is High Praise And Magnus how
much you know kind of a weird question
but how much does that does that
motivate you right and no way would we
compare online Bullet to the many titles
You've Won in your career World
Championships Rapids and Blitz but how
motivated do you get when you play a
format where you're like huh like this
guy's better than me at this right does
that motivate you already even in
looking ahead
yeah I love it I
I'm just really happy that I managed to
get to to the final and I didn't make a
complete fool of myself like if
uh uh I mean if I'd been blown out in
the final that would have been been fine
just getting there was was good but
overall this is uh very good result for
me I think
you know
um
if I if I was completely arrested you
know maybe I'd have um I'd have a chance
to
to upset him and like
I'm yeah like I think he's certainly
better but
maybe at at uh at my best
um I'm I'm like good enough that it's
it's not a shock if I if I if I win and
I mean I can try to to improve a little
bit I I don't suspect that I'll be
practicing a lot
um to be honest like most of the time I
just find something bullet pretty little
really stressful but um
but we'll see uh I gotta say also
before the match against the Carlos as I
said like I was extremely happy to get
there but I felt like I'd already sort
of expanded so much not so much energy
uh but more like nervous energy in the
in the match against
alireza fortunately I like the game the
match against the ridiculous pretty
comfortable but I I felt I felt a bit
drained after after the match with that
already but I'm happy uh it was it was a
good match uh and um I think overall you
know
I'm pretty pretty proud actually of my
performance here
you should be proud of it for sure
Magnus on that note of you felt like you
expend a lot of energy we were Danny and
I were talking as the match was
beginning at zakaru did you feel like
you would be uh with the advantage
because you were in the flow you've been
playing bullet for a few hours or that
the rest was more important so do you
think that it would have made a
difference if you had more time
separated between your match against
alireza and your match against agaro
the rest is more important also because
there is always some sense of uh
sense of flow
um
but uh I mean in terms of um in terms of
rest I don't think it's about you know
those hours necessarily it's probably
more that I should have uh spent my time
this week a bit differently if I wanted
to
if I wanted to optimize my results but
um that's um
yeah that's fine I don't I don't
yeah I don't think you know the racing
time made made a massive difference you
know so we say I I think it's a slight
Advantage but um not a big deal
more rest better bullet right who would
have known I only have one more question
Magnus I I texted you between the Donya
match and the other match about holding
alt when you promote did you know that
when he did that stalemate trick if you
hold alt and you take you can get you
can get a knight you know that yeah I I
know it just didn't occur to me that I
could underpromise okay it's just yeah I
mean at that point like I was I already
like had my guard down uh yeah yeah of
course actually I tried the same thing
yesterday
um in that I I think we started this
last game with like eight seconds left
or something and I tried to start the
last game against uh Andrew as well just
you know so that we can get one more
game of practice but um
yeah no I I I I I knew it I I don't know
if I've ever done it actually
so like if you're playing me in bullet
like yeah and uh I have to promote
tonight I I'll probably lose some time
uh well you know it's something to for
someone to prepare against you and we
did ask the chat for some questions and
Galaxy milk 100 first of all great
username I wanted to know how did you
prepare for your match against icaro did
you do anything before your other
matches today or in the break or
anything like that
um no I mean I had I had an energy drink
and I tried to I poured some water into
my face and I don't
I tried to
um
yeah I didn't I didn't know uh didn't
know what to do like
uh yeah he's he's so good
also as I said earlier like my main
advantage is that I can play faster and
like
if I don't have that it's really
it's really it's really tough
I got one more question as well from
teacher Chad and I think you kind of
already answered this Magnus but we want
the fans to get their questions in from
the hill 2501 once Magnus can you please
explain the mouse Arc for the last
couple days maybe that was part of being
home that your actual physical setup was
different
yeah that's the thing though like I'm a
little bit a little bit faster from
or totally a lot faster
um even though I'm still still slow
um so so yeah I also like
I like the screen the bigger screen
better I feel like I see the board
geometrical things in a better way even
though you know I still
blunder um every second move but so does
everybody
makes mistakes yeah it's true and thanks
so much for your thoughts Max we'll let
you go but I do want to wish you the
best of luck in the upcoming World Cup
since I know that event is starting soon
but thanks so much for joining us and I
know second place isn't first but
congrats on really an awesome
performance
yeah thank you I'm really happy
Thea Magnus
that was great great interview there
from the world number one former world
champion I don't even know how to say
that anymore I'm just awkward
um but uh it does take second place
Robert I think our Nakamura is the man
on top of the mall at the end of the day
oh he is he was the defending Champion
he's the champion once more and Magnus
Carlson slots there in second place and
his words you said everything you needed
to hear Hikaru is just so darn good I
mean what does anybody on this planet
have to do to overtake Hikaru and bullet
that's a question that remains
unanswered but I'm just happy to hear
that Magnus is happy not just as a
person but the fact that he could lose a
match and something just like wow that
opponent is scary good and he impressed
me
it shows what a sportsman he is and I
and I um I know how he feels about
playing in formats where he doesn't
consider himself the favorite he loves
it he drives and and and and wants those
opportunities
um and uh you know obviously he didn't
get this one today I think a momentum
turning into exhaustion thing right as
he said maybe he didn't spend his week
um in a way that allowed for the most
energy even here on a Friday um but
but despite how complimentary he was
Robert as you said it was a very close
match came down to overtime
although I do also agree with him and I
think you would too that if we had to
think back about games that got away
from someone there were more games that
got away from Hikaru that he probably
should have won so the truth is Hikaru
is just so bleeping good at bullet right
and Magnus felt that today despite how
close it was in complimentary he was
there's a reason Nakamura is the guy at
the end of the day
yeah no Hikaru just stands Atop The
Mountain as the bullet Champion he
earned it as you just said and as Magnus
admitted that Hikaru had some
opportunity slip out of his fingertips
and it maybe could have been a different
match but still it was into overtime it
was a two-point win for Hikaru Nakamura
Magnus Carlsen and I guess I have one
final question for you well I have two
first I just thought about this you
didn't ask Magnus about Nickelback so go
text him right now and ask him for his
favorite song so we can tell everybody
before the show ends but you know more
relevant
what or who impressed you most about
this event and what do you look forward
to for next year
wow
um
honestly I'm gonna I'm gonna say this
like I mean this totally genuinely
I was impressed by The Format as a fan I
will be honest I've never watched this
much of the bullet Chess Championship
before because in past years Robert I
commentated with you or there were there
was a year where I didn't but I'll be
honest I didn't get to watch that much I
was impressed by how enjoyable this was
because I think sometimes bullet
you know presents in a way that's almost
too fast right you don't get those
instructive moments that you get and
even just a little bit slower chest
three minute or five minute but this was
so much fun it was so much fun to watch
the matches were so hype and it was so
close so I just I'm gonna say like the
format was the most impressive it was an
amazing show to watch you were
incredible
um I really mean that and I I but then I
also will say at the end of the day that
Hikaru Nakamura just continues to
deliver it's insane it's insane and even
though he says uh what he does about
about being a streamer the truth is he
is probably playing the best chess of
his career and I think it probably is
true that regardless of whether you got
to that phrase as a meme or not the fact
that he literally doesn't care has
somehow brought out the best of his
talents and it's crazy to watch and so
much fun to think that we will have
future matches where these two guys are
playing
um for probably for years to come
and I don't remember where I first heard
it but it's good to be nervous because
you care but not because you're scared
Hikaru Nakamura if he ever was scared he
is scared no more of Magnus Carlson
there's a ton of mutual respect there
and it earns this title ahead of magnets
just like he did at the 2022 speed Chess
Championship and this concludes the
event that is the bullet Chess
Championship but we have more great
events for you it may not be played at a
lightning Pace it may not involve Hikaru
or Magnus but we have POG Champs 5
starting at the end of the month 16 of
the world's biggest creators will go
head to head in the greatest event in
amateur chess brought to you by
chess.com and pop Champs Legend Ludwig
watch your favorite creators like cutie
Cinderella Sea Dog VA xqc tyler1 I did a
thing and the others fight for their
share of a 100
000 prize fund and a ticket to the live
finals where Danny wrench will be in Los
Angeles use the command POG in chat for
all the details Denny
also it may not even have good chess
sorry I thought you're gonna say they
don't even have good chests but it's
great and then we already teased some of
the players I didn't know we were gonna
do that but yeah tyler1 is playing this
year there's some other really big names
that are joining we're gonna tease later
so I'm sorry I stole your thunder as you
send us send us out here but go ahead
man you you could never steal my thunder
unless it's Tropic Thunder but we should
probably not talk about that movie on
air but no I was gonna no longer okay
it's always a true pleasure to be joined
by you I mean over the years and we've
commented so many events and so many
different venues online different time
patrols different formats uh but it's
always an absolute pleasure especially
for as you said this format win Bike 2
Double Elimination bullet chess Hikaru
Magnus only raise adanya we've seen it
all and we've had a blast
I don't even know that I got much else
to say you're the man much love you
crushed it this week this was so much
fun fans Circle your calendar for
whenever we announced the bullet just
Championship next year because it's
gonna be just as lit and uh thank you
for having me Robert
oh it's always a pleasure and thanks to
everybody who's tuned in each and every
day we appreciate every one of you
thanks for the thoughtful questions
thanks for supporting all the players
and just thanks for loving chess so
until next time this has been Robert
Hess and Danny wrenchen we appreciate
you all have a good one
only 13 minutes remain right now well we
have a blender
I'm just gonna get it with the fist bump
Magnus is almost in the territory where
he can just start letting the clock hit
it's stalemate if you take the Rook
that's what's going on here
I am calling the momentum Mount Magnus
has already won a match today he's
looking fresh feeling fresh in his home
environment and Perugia is going to win
his sixth game in a row bullet it's a
it's a game of momentum more than
anything else and Perugia is on fire
right now
Magnus Carlson has turned this thing
around and now he's bobbing his head to
music again aruja needs to find it whoa
he resigns seconds early and Perugia
leans back and Magnus is celebrating
Magus moves on to the Grand Final and uh
and Magnus is going to level things up
in this game unless something wild
happens he also has a huge Edge on the
clock unreal play thus far from ikari's
fast he's playing very accurately and
he's getting to the end games where he
can play for two results as we say in
classical chess Magnus he wins a quick
game there it's only a two-point spread
10 seconds Here Comes
God
Supreme of King h8 and he's just losing
the game if I look at Magnus just get
those Queens off the board and then oh
he didn't have to the car resigned the
car going in the way there was a blunder
we'd be six yeah this part is promoting
he allowed the queen in the party you
see it on magnus's face he knows that
does it it's how they call Nakamura
defended his bullet Chess Championship
title
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]